there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey you guys it's episode 160
tale yeah we got Dennis with look he's
join me that's up to the Dennis Rader
bobblehead this is given to Jani from
Sophie yeah our friend Sophie gave it oh
my goodness
thanks Sophia I know thank you so Mike a
limited edition came in a box with it's
like a number than everything from
psycho killer yeah yeah look at the
charm the bag yeah I think it's what
fifty five fifty something out this
website and see what other ones they got
cuz I seriously I opened this up and I
just like laughed my ass off
Sookie Obama is I know now when I do the
voice I'm gonna do Dennis's voice
they'll talk you know I can you can like
put it yeah I get a little head shake
around yeah you know Jenni oh I always
knew that they would make a bobblehead
of me I'm a cultural icon I'll do all on
the back of my you know sexual problem
doctor problem yeah well Dennis you
should be very proud you I'm very proud
maybe they'll make a Funko pop of you as
well they probably have do they have
those of serial killers that would I
mean they have one of like every other
conceivable yeah fictional character
they're not cool enough they're not on
the serial killer train yeah
they wrote you know you know how they
are they're trying to make money and
trying to you know put on a good face
for the kids and you know they're more
into superheroes and things like that
yeah lame [ __ ] one day when they get
cool they want to make money you know
them they might make a generator you
know Funko pop thing
you call it yeah yeah that's cheap cheap
bulb things you know we already had when
he's high class company come make me
make a bobblehead of me it it's it's a
lot better than a phone call it's solid
that's all those other things are hollow
this thing's solved weighs a ton
represent some you know how solid I am
as a man anyway you get back on the show
thank you very much Dennis I'm sure who
will be hearing your insight later on in
the show because we're doing another
technically not a serial killer more
like a mass murderer because most of his
murders happened at one time this is
Richard Speck now Oh hammy I'm dressing
like a woman okay
I know some guys a good time or them
can't keep that dick out of his mouth
[Laughter]
you know real man wouldn't do that Jenny
Thank You Dennis real man my dress up as
a woman you know get down inside you
know hole ground take take a salt itself
of course boy you know I never suggest
otherwise I was that's just art you know
it's like a message to the police it's
not you know it doesn't mean that you
know I like to dress it's a form of
communication mystic expression but yeah
so Richards back is probably I think
he's been like our most fertile and I
didn't put a dick in my mouth I mention
equipment me make this clear I didn't
put a dick in my mouth okay okay I'm not
so you know I what are you guys getting
you know I wouldn't do that
yeah okay yeah look I know you probably
can't see it cuz it's too small but he
has like a little knife in his hand and
his other hand he has a little cross
yeah because you know that's how they I
don't think I ever cut a [ __ ] though
just strangle a [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
did have a knife but you know I didn't I
don't think I used it you know well you
know long time ago you've moved on from
that but yeah I think Richards Beck has
probably been our most requested true
crime topic and I was gonna get around
to it I was actually gonna do it next
month but then I was looking at the
topics for this week and I was just kind
of like [ __ ] it let's do Richard's back
this week cuz I had been wanting to talk
about it
but yeah so before we do that let's get
into just a couple of little shout outs
like we usually do as I said thank you
very much Sophie for my early birthday
presents my birthday's on the 26th which
I guess that'll be two days after this
show goes up on Tuesday the 24th so
that's my little early birthday present
thank you very much for that um I also
want to thank our newest patron whose
name is Keith hey there man thank you
very much for your support and also a
big THANK YOU to Jason who sent us a
very generous PayPal donation just this
morning yeah thanks Jason thank you very
much for your support it really is on
for my bucks like 50 bucks it's like
really does help a lot yeah and you know
so that was a significant portion of our
damn YouTube money it is yeah well
actually
YouTube YouTube doesn't pay us that much
it has to be well they pay you monthly
if you're if it's over a hundred dollars
is that what it is
okay yeah it goes over a hundred dollars
they pay most of its from patrons yeah
yeah
and you know like I said occasional
graphic design work that's money from
that too
um again a faceless villain three is up
in all three formats print ebook audio
so go check it out I think I mentioned
last week but the conspiratorial show
that I did that could spear normal
podcast with Adam saying I did a an
interview on there where I talked about
a bunch of the cases that are in
faceless villain 3 and that is up I'll
put a link in the description below
[ __ ] didn't talk about me
either they caught your dumb ass about
me when you're not talking about me
Jenny I feel lonely Oh No yeah you
should we should have bought a church
together I wish I mean you went to
church yeah you like to take pictures
Jenny I'll let you get back to the show
I don't mean to be butting in yet I'm a
humble man I was looking I see him and I
get inspired good to channel this
channel the living spirit channeling the
living spirit of [ __ ] it's like
what's like I that movie freaks you know
where she could ask me project--and yeah
channel people and images and [ __ ]
that's my link with with Dennis and
crustle oh yeah yeah all right and the
only other thing that I wanted to shout
out was as I said before one of my
horror fiction compilation short story
collections The Associated villanies I
just recently put out a second edition
which has four extra stories and you
know it's I corrected anything that was
wrong I mean a new cover design I did
all this other stuff and the print
version an e-book of that is up the
audio version has been uploaded but it's
still undergoing quality control so
that'll probably be like another week or
two before that's up and I'm also
working on my other short story
collection hopeful monsters and the
print version of that is almost done and
then I have to do an e-book and then I'm
gonna record an audio book version of
that as well so that will be also be out
a couple of months like I said I'm
consolidating all my fiction and yeah
yeah and better better on you
well there wasn't even audio that before
then yeah I never did figure my fiction
next we're gonna consolidate all the
Steve Merrill work and stuff there's
gonna be two new Steve Mira stories
large stories before they would have
come out as books
but we have those two new stories at
least two maybe three yeah better no
long there and the other two like fired
and whispers and Rochdale poltergeist
they will all be in a collection and it
will all be on audiobook and a better
version of the audio because we have the
new equipment yeah so you know we're
consolidating the catalog and yeah my
training all three of everything yeah
and updating all the audio quality yeah
so that'll be like the next project
probably next year sometime but yeah so
that's all that's going on there I think
that's pretty much all the Shonan I'd
say we had I think that's all I can
remember so let's start talking about
Richard Speck yeah like I said
technically he's not classified as a
serial killer because most of his iconic
crimes he killed at least eight women
but he killed them all at once like in
one night however prior to that he did
commit several rapes and at least one
murder that they suspect was him
but you know couldn't prove it yeah so I
guess you could kind of classify him as
a serial killer even though he didn't
really operate he didn't confess to it
uh no not that I know of there is some
video of this guy floating around which
is yeah super special um it didn't kind
of come to light until later it's maybe
after he died even but yeah I'll get
into that later on cuz that's like
personal pretty creepy [ __ ] I'm talking
about his prison videos yeah oh yeah
you've seen those right of course as
Dennis you know you know I see all that
kind of stuff so let's talk about
dressing like a woman yeah he did leader
in prison yeah yeah Dick's in his mouth
they said I dressed as a woman but it
was for artistic purposes just making it
clear you're protesting about that a lot
no I'm not no I'm not shut up shut up
just making it making things clear okay
well thank you very much I appreciate
you doing that all right so let's talk
about Richard Speck this little life
we'll start at the beginning of his sad
miserable life and here we go
so Richard Speck was actually born in
Kirkwood which is like a rural part of
Illinois about six miles southwest of
Monmouth he was actually born the day
before Pearl Harbor like the bombing of
Pearl Harbor and I heard like a bit of
an interview with him where he said like
you know oh the day before I was born
you know and then the next day like all
hell broke loose and it hasn't stopped
since so yeah I guess he's kind of saw
himself he's very important yeah I guess
well he did have kind of like a thing
like that where he thought that he was
like destined to make headlines and in a
bad way he wasn't one of those people
that's like oh I'm gonna walk on the
moon or gonna be famous for good [ __ ] he
seemed like he was always like oh I'm
gonna shock the world I'm gonna do every
time I saw any video this guy back
before you know like you know before the
when before the infamous videos the
prison videos yeah he always tried to
come he always came across it's just
like really white trash and and kind of
a wannabe um
country-western star in a way kind of
what's you Johnny Cash kind of like a
wannabe Johnny Cash yeah but a very
low-budget version of it that's why he
always kind of came across to me I mean
I don't know maybe it's just me yeah he
was he did seem like he was kind of like
wanted to be like a low-rent tough guy
yeah and kind of thing like he's a man
of mystery and all that kind but really
the no intellect speak of just know he
seemed like kind of it just dumb ass
yeah yeah but yeah so he's born in kind
of rural Illinois he was actually the
seventh of eight children his dad's name
is Benjamin Franklin spec very nice and
his mom's name was Mary
um now spec had a younger sister named
Carolyn and that but that was only two
years younger but their other siblings
were like way older than them so you
know what I mean so that was the two of
them young and then that was like some
older ones he also had an older brother
named Robert who died when he was 23 in
a car wreck now when spec was born uh
his dad worked as a packer in a place
Western stone where in Monmouth and also
did kind of like odd jobs he was a
farmer in a lager now his dad was by all
accounts very close to Richard Speck I
mean they were like and and he really
really idolized his dad like his dad
would take him fishing his and his
family were like really hard-working you
know they didn't have a lot of money and
stuff and obviously they had like a [ __ ]
ton of kids and they had just like this
kind of little modest house and stuff
but they were always like working really
hard to like provide for the kids and
stuff like that so in the early days
they were poor but it wasn't like an
abusive relationship or anything now the
mom was they were Presbyterians and she
was a pretty hardcore religious as in
one of those no smoking no drinking no
nothing kind of people yeah um one one
source that I read said that even the
dad got in trouble one time they were
like it a fish fry or a barbecue or
something he drank a beer and she just
like reamed him Anubis oh no I didn't
mean he's just like no alcohol was
allowed likes you know so so there was
that whole thing - yeah but it's a
journey he he doesn't know how to keep
his woman in check who actually wore the
pants in the family
oh this may be where the problems began
with Richard you know I mean mr. Peck
because a man has to wear the pants in
the family you can't let the woman just
tell you what to do like if a man wants
to drink a beer he drinks a beer the man
wants to wear women's clothes nod their
mind I've said too much change of
subject go ahead you yeah by all
accounts like his mom was very religious
and very strict but like I said they
weren't abusive and later on he did seem
to idolize his mother like find her very
saintly and stuff like that now a
problem arose when his father died when
he was six years old
the dad had a heart attack when it had
heart attack when he was only 53 now
after the death of his father
spec's seemed to you know he was six
years old but he seemed to like regress
like back to top toddlerhood like some
of his teachers said that he would be in
class
he would like start eating crayons he
would start like just acting like a baby
like to get attention from his teachers
and stuff so the death of his dad like
really really affected him because
apparently they were very close and like
I said he was just a little kid at the
time it was six years old now two or
three years later it happens that his
mother Mary met this guy he was a
traveling insurance salesman and he was
from Texas and his name was Karl August
Rudolph Lindbergh now they met on a
train trip which she was going to
Chicago
now by all accounts Lindbergh was the
complete opposite of specks real dad
this guy was a boozehound he was a
criminal he had like a lot of you know
criminal history generally of like
forgery drunk driving that type of stuff
that's not acceptable
yeah rules and a man has to follow
certain rules yeah why I don't know how
tall the grass can be you have to know
where the dog can be where it can't be
how long the leash ask how long the
leash has to be there's a many things
man you must keep [ __ ] under control why
I didn't know you swore Dennis well when
it's serious issues they hired me to you
know keep [ __ ] under control
sometimes a man even have to keep these
hoes under control Jenni yeah yeah yeah
well if they're not helping you deal
with your sexual problems I don't want
to talk about my sexual problems right
now usually you're so forthcoming on
that score though I'm not ready okay
it's already maybe later on maybe after
a few maybe me and you can talk about
sex we have a camera I have a really
nice church that I belong to after hours
it's nice and quiet maybe me and you
ought to hang out play around on a
computer
bring your camera okay [ __ ] you dad as
we were lying
I haven't been myself on the whole shop
and I was gonna say sounds like gonna
start developing a split personality
it's gonna be like [ __ ] it was gonna
be like that [ __ ] scary movie with
Anthony Hopkins in it magic like him in
the venture that's all I need now I need
a dent I need a Dennis Rader
ventriloquist dummy yeah yeah and then
like you're like I said you'll start to
like develop a dual personality yeah no
thanks then I'll get murdered
see you guys yeah you guys know he's
dressed up like a woman taking pictures
of you and [ __ ] yeah yeah that's exactly
what I picture happening this is how it
starts so not only was the new dad
stepdad not only was he a drunk not only
was he a criminal with a 25 year long
rap sheet for various things he also
really really hated Richard Speck and
like I said Richard Speck was only
probably eight or nine years old at the
time there's probably the beginnings of
his problem yeah it really does seem
like it because like I said before that
he seemed like a pretty normal kid he
wasn't a great student or anything like
he wasn't like super bright or anything
but he seemed like otherwise through a
bunch of conflicts happiness what his
mom had all these suck in high standards
and he like he didn't really like his
mom that much but his dad probably
defended him he liked his dad his dad
died and replaced him and then he got
replaced with the antithesis of his dad
and the antithesis of what is what was
what his mother believed in so he
started to see the world was like
hypocrisy yeah I imagine that was
probably it right where well she had all
these rules you know but now she's
blowing him off for this guy women just
they're just all about dick probably
where this all began yeah possibly and
like I said he did really develop a very
very um hatred towards women well it he
had a really bad Madonna [ __ ] calm down
there it is right there big time and
several psychologists said that so the
dad you know would call him things like
a gutter rat he's like you know I can't
stand the sight of you all this other
kind of [ __ ] so obviously not very good
yes his mom's preferring this new guy
who's the opposite mm-hmm
what he's used to smiles preferring the
new guy over him yeah you know so he's
trying to suspect feels he's being
displaced by this guy who's a piece of
[ __ ] yeah yeah and not only that but
because Lindbergh was from Texas they
all actually ended up moving to Texas
now they let Richard Speck stay him and
his little sister Carolyn stayed with
their one of their older sisters who was
already older and married in Monmouth
Illinois well so he could finish out the
school year but then they moved to Santo
Texas which is about 40 miles west of
force Fort Worth and then he started
back at school going to the third grade
and then after that so not only does he
have like a new dad who he hates you
know a whole new situation but now you
know he's only eight years old maybe and
he's forced to like move to Texas he's
you know he's so he's moved away from
everything he knew previously so at this
stage after they moved to Texas Oh
over the next like 12 years or so they
had they kept moving like from place to
place like from one poor neighborhood to
another poor neighborhood because like I
said they'd have a huge amount of money
the step dad Lindbergh was as I said a
drunk he was just kind of like not there
a lot of the time and [ __ ] like that
Richard Speck was apparently he had
vision problems but he didn't he
wouldn't tell anybody about them and he
wouldn't wear glasses
so he would go to school and he couldn't
really see anything but he wouldn't tell
anybody because he was like really shy
and he didn't want people looking at him
so he didn't do very well in school
because he couldn't see what the [ __ ]
was going on and wouldn't wear any
glasses now he starts ninth grade in
1957 but he failed every single subject
and in January 1958 he dropped out just
after his 16th birthday now what one
thing that he had done starting when he
was age 12 was one way that he would get
back at his stepdad was when his stepdad
was out he would raid this.look liquor
cabinet so he started getting drunk
when he was 12 years old now by the time
he was 15 or 16 he was getting drunk
pretty much every day and he had also
kind of fallen in with this other crowd
of boys that introduced him to like
marijuana and various pills and started
kind of teaching him how to do like
basic little criminal activities like
how to break into places and like
various scams and things like that so
he's already getting in with a bad crowd
at this point his first arrest was at
age 13 actually this was trespassing but
he had like a whole bunch of other
arrests over the next few years mostly
for minor [ __ ] it was just like you know
burglaries exposing himself just [ __ ]
like that
he also started when he got a bit older
and started hanging out with these other
boys he also started frequenting
prostitutes you know and getting into
sex with the older girls that they hung
out with they think that this was about
the time that he developed the Madonna
[ __ ] complex because like I said he had
he didn't have quite the resentment
toward his mother that a lot of serial
killers have he sort of did but then he
also sort of saw hers like saintly and
pure so if a woman was quote-unquote
easy or was not like his mother then she
didn't mean it then he had contempt for
her you know what I mean
so everyone was either like his mom or
just a [ __ ] that you could you know do
whatever you want to do with yeah but I
guarantee you he had some of that he had
some anger towards her - oh I'm sure he
did I'm sure he did all this shit's
getting confused in his mind you know
just kind of a general he probably has
an idealized version of what a woman
should be but then he started seeing
these bad examples of hookers and [ __ ]
but deep down he thinks they're all
about the same yeah I definitely think
that that's probably what's going on in
him because he's probably like yeah my
mom pretending his subconscious he's
like yeah mom pretended to have all
these [ __ ] but I she married time
yeah high moral values but she didn't
live up to that so it's like I said she
was like no drinking
yeah smoking though anything and then
she married a drunk right it was all so
abusive not only abusive toward the
children but also abusive toward her
right you know what I'm not sure if it
was physically or just emotionally but
you know it doesn't really matter in
this context cuz they're both bad yes he
starts whew he starts to repeat it like
you know sex is power yeah that's how
he's reading into it yeah yep
so Richard Speck actually gets a job as
a laborer at the 7-up bottling company
in Dallas and he worked there for about
three years now in October of 1961 he
met this fifteen-year-old girl named
Shirley Malone they met at the Texas
State Fair and they started dating now
they were only dating for three weeks
and she got pregnant
so this was the early 60s so they got
married right so she moves in with
Richard Speck who still lived at home at
this point
moved in with him his mom and his
younger sister Carolyn and Carolyn's
husband or I think Carolyn was the older
sister so Carolyn and Carolyn's husband
the mom and whoever now by this point
the mom and the stepfather had separated
so so Lindbergh had moved away and he'd
moved to California so he wasn't in
Richards Beck's life anymore so he went
back to cuz I guess when the when the
mom had married Lindbergh speck had
taken his last name for a little while
because he was still a little kid and
that's just what you did back then but
he reverted back to his dad's name like
after that guy left and after he got
married now as should not be surprising
Richard Speck was not super nice to his
wife emotionally abusive physically
abusive he had a thing where he was
convinced that she was cheating on him
even though there was no evidence that
she was but he was apparently allowed to
go out to hookers all the time and would
even do some [ __ ] like he would go pick
up a hooker and then he would drive and
park with the hooker in front of his
house and then make sure that his wife
was looking out the window and then
would start
with the hooker and then he would drive
off like laughing at her he thought and
she was pregnant at the time he thought
he was getting revenge somehow yeah
first he thought she was cheating on him
yeah but you know what I mean he's
[ __ ] paranoid yeah
well see it it seems like one of those
cases where this is a guy where he's a
piece of [ __ ] right he projects that on
everybody he thinks everyone else is as
big a piece of [ __ ] he is he's
projecting even though nobody like
hardly anybody is yeah so he just feels
like so I think that in that way they
feel justified in acting like that
because he said oh well I'm just the
only like everybody else wants to be
like that everybody else is like that
and I'm just the only one with the balls
to like be like that he's got issues
clearly yeah yeah so when um when his
wife gave birth to their daughter whose
name was Robbie Lynn she was born in
1962 and so she's in the hospital giving
birth and she had no [ __ ] idea where
Richard Speck was turned out later that
he was in jail in McKinney Texas they've
been like a big drunk and fight at some
bar everywhere and he so he was serving
a 22 day sentence for disturbing the
peace
okay so the next time he was gonna came
in contact with law enforcement was in
July 1963 he was caught he forged and
cashed a co-worker's paycheck which was
for $44 and then he burglarized a
grocery store
he stole like a [ __ ] ton of cigarettes
and started like and I don't know if
this was the time that he did that but
he he what he would do is he would steal
a bunch of cartons of cigarettes from a
grocery store and then he would sell
them out of the trunk of his car like in
the parking lot yeah so you know back in
those days cigarettes weren't worth much
yeah so it's like what it seemed dumb
but it's like why is why in the parking
lot so you could go up and buy
cigarettes from a dude selling
cigarettes out of a trunk of a car in a
parking lot when you can just walk into
the grocery store and buy them and I'm
sure some for a discount I guess he must
have been it's like not for cheaper I
don't know man I wouldn't trust H they
were cheap back then
so I don't know you know what I don't
know you guys just scraping bottom of
the barrel
I guess oh man yeah you get a pack of
stickers for what a quarter probably no
I'm kind of curious he was like the
early 60 because it turned like so many
of his robberies like in this particular
robbery where he stole this or he robbed
this grocery store he stole like some
beer and [ __ ] he stole three dollars in
cash yeah
which now I'm gonna have to like look up
I'll probably put it down here like in
writing what everyone how much that is
listen to his money when I was a kid
back in the 70s out in California I
remember riding around my dad in his car
and they would buy a car for like about
a thousand dollars he bought a Ford
Cortina and it was a piece of [ __ ] I
think it's like $1,000 or some brand new
and then abandon it when it broke cuz it
was cheap a gallon of gas thing was
nothing it was before the the gas crisis
yes and a pack of cigarettes was like 25
cents yeah I remember him being
religious yeah my dad was just you know
I'm working at a water pollution control
plant he wasn't a rich guy he worked for
the city yeah you have long beach I
think was Long Beach California and you
know they would just buy cigarettes by
the cartons nowadays a carton of
cigarettes of probably what $25 yeah hey
no more than that they're more than that
now maybe yeah I think so it depends on
what kind of cigarettes they are they
weren't taxed yeah yeah I mean they
didn't have any kind of big heavy taxes
on them they were just like it's like
buying a pack pack pack of chewing gum
yeah I remember when my grandfather cuz
my grandfather used to smoke so much it
he got emphysema so yeah they smoked
back then man let in phew yeah you just
buddy he smoked salem's yeah that's it
my grandmother no she quit later on but
he never did it was he had have an
oxygen tank like later on but he would
but he would buy just like three four
cartons on it was awesome me know that I
mean I remember my mom had come back
with just huge big old stacks of steak
that [ __ ] was cheap although I guess I
don't think steak was that cheap because
we never we hardly ever had it when I
can the seven is in California it was
cheap well not here not cheap cheaper
than it was today yeah you know I mean
it's kind of like well special you know
I mean we always had like gonna cost you
about 40 bucks like dirt
down at Sam's to get you some pack of
steaks yeah but they weren't that much
in California like I'm talking about
like 75 76 that's that's this a time
period I can remember remember that they
had all that you know it was different
time yeah I mean I remember having steak
every now and then but usually if we had
beef it was like either hamburger or it
was like one of those super super cheap
tough really yeah
you must been poor we were kind of poor
for that period of time it's not like
Salisbury steak not everybody was kind
of moving up and I remember you know
remember we had all that we had a lot of
beef a lot of chicken and we like never
ate out I mean seriously going to
McDonald's was like a huge deal yeah we
going to McDonald's was a huge deal for
you yeah yeah going you know and go to
like Arthur Treacher's that was like oh
my god that was like that would make my
[ __ ] year well I guess you say what's
that place with my family upper
working-class and then they were up
early mobile they got more and more
wealthy as they went I mean they were
young yeah when I'm talking when I'm you
know they were in their 20s in the 70s
yeah you know maybe 25 26 I'm like that
27 well like I said my parents were very
young when they had me yeah they were
only just out of high school there were
only 18 in 1972 and and then they also
had three more kids like later on so
right yeah that was only child so they
have the head yeah so you got like all
the attention I got all the toys - man I
got all the toys I only I have my
parents to myself for four years and
then my brother was I had Evel Knievel
toys I had Star Wars toys I had all the
Shogun warriors and [ __ ] you know and I
still got show I know you so god I'm the
big big ones and a little ones there and
I love that [ __ ] you're a spoiled brat
well now a child you know yeah yeah you
know I always wondered what that would
be like I was only an old like I said I
was only an only child until high school
sucks like our cat yeah she's like our
daughter from hell it's like that we go
there
yeah suck is so [ __ ] funny okay well
we put Pookie videos video
yes that catch a trip I'm getting [ __ ]
up - yes you see it I see that - hold it
together for the show
yeah you better hold it together Tommy
you stop drinking yeah I drew the show
yeah that's pretty much love it like
every now and like sometimes we drink in
the evening yeah we're just watching
movies or something and we drink when we
go out obviously but our regular list
listeners like it when we go off track
like this when we go off track of the
show it's part of the show well you're a
lawyer it makes it longer most of us are
at work or they're commuting or they're
laying down bed with headphones on try
and go sleep this is just you know I do
the same [ __ ] thing okay yeah so I
understand the content you know because
I I have people I listen to also yeah
thinking about doing a special series of
martial arts frauds and the history of
martial arts because with a main dude
that I liked man the weird that's the
guy we were talking I think man showed
us a countdown yeah so I'm gonna have to
pick all those videos down I have to
pick up the gauntlet well yeah I may
have to do it like I said we still have
to do like our food show - because I'm
super excited about that we should do
that yeah somebody like I said somebody
somebody commented I'm like on our
YouTube that we should do a show every
day
we can't do a show like a we got so much
other stuff going on I know like if I if
I wasn't doing writing and wasn't doing
graphic design I might because then I
have more time but and most you can't we
do three shows a week that's pretty and
like I said I might actually end up
doing that Food Show but we're not gonna
do that every week that we might just do
it like twice a month or something and
some people have noticed you know the
regulars have noticed that you know I'm
not always banging on all cylinders you
know because I get tired well no that
gets sick sometimes - really what I need
to do is if we were to ever do some [ __ ]
like that
we'd have to set like three days a week
aside and do nothing but record yeah
right that's really how I keep saying
that we should do that for this show but
we just never end up - never really
never really ends up happening
because we get sidetracked by stuff by
other stuff because like I said well
it's because we're both I mean he's
retired I'm like on the gig economy so I
have like three different [ __ ] jobs
and so I never really know like I wake
up in the morning and I have like a set
thing it's like okay X X Y Z that has to
get done today but then I don't know
like if other shits gonna come up
because like I said I have a lot of
graphic design clients and there's like
oh my god I need this thing right now
and like it then I have to put
everything else aside and do that and
like you know I mean so I never know
exactly like when I'm gonna go and I
have no sense of time yeah I have to
like Siri she's like my secretary I have
to record we do yeah I thought we just
recorded she's like well that was three
days ago
yeah yeah I had no sense of time I had
that all just beaten out of me over the
years yeah yeah I can sit I could sit in
one spot for like three months and not
notice it yeah I think that's true yeah
I think that's true I'm happy I know I
have to watch him though because like
yesterday I think you were he made this
like really good beep steel like at the
crockpot yeah and he was reheating some
of it so he can have it for lunch yeah
and he went back in the room and go
watching YouTube and forgot all about it
yeah and like I came I'm like you are
gonna burn this [ __ ] house down what
do these dates I had that I had that
motorcycle accident that put me in a
coma I had that [ __ ] you had a frontal
left interventricular brain hemorrhage
and time was never the same after that
yeah yeah I'm always scared like I
always have like I feel like I don't
want okay I hate being a nag and I hate
like having to like remind you of [ __ ]
all the time because I feel like I'm
like you know Anna weighing you and
stuff you are but I know I don't like I
don't like being annoying but you know I
lost that internal clock yeah but it's
like I always have to like seriously
every time he cuz cuz he mostly cooks
cuz I don't really like to cook and he's
a really good cook but every time like
after he cooks I have to go back in and
make sure he turned off the stove and
then it's turned off the oven and all
this other kind of stuff like I just
have to check because I don't know head
injuries are a [ __ ] curse and a
blessing simultaneous we're seeing the
series they were seen that Netflix
series The Punisher
he got shot through the head and then he
put his damn
had x-ray on his [ __ ] shirt you know
I mean that yeah because he was getting
all that superpowers from his [ __ ]
head injury I got that yeah I can she's
seen me I can get mad I can get very
strong and I don't have any sense of
time which means that I have unlimited
willpower yeah it's just that I just
don't know how much time has passed well
I mean in a way it's weird Len like you
said it's other people are getting bored
or they'll give up and I haven't even
noticed the passage of time
yeah so mom after your ass and if it
takes four or five years I don't even
know - he doesn't know I won't even
notice that it took I like the [ __ ]
terminator but this is like and this is
why like sometimes I find this like
especially like recording the show and
stuff like that and like why sometimes I
find it like very frustrating because
it's like I will remind I have to remind
him like the night before I'll be like
okay we have to record a show tomorrow
like it yeah you know at X time or
whatever and then like I'll remind him
again in the morning like when he gets
up we got to do a show today so don't
forget about it you know like kind of
get jazzed up for it everything like
that and then I'll be in here like I'll
have the lights on off the mic set up
I'll have all the notes of everything in
it and then I'm sitting here and I'm
just like yeah it's a funny [ __ ] because
I have to come in here and like what
hello and he's like oh I forgot about
some funny [ __ ] cuz I'll remember
something that somebody told me 20 years
ago I'll remember all this I couldn't
tell you what time it was no he never
knows or or what day it was or kind of
the month
all that [ __ ] kind of it doesn't matter
we're just going along we're riding away
that's just one thing after another well
I have to keep Matt right I have to keep
your exactly because otherwise nothing
would ever get done right
nothing like none of my work whatever
gets on I would never get paid so I have
to keep trying things weather or what
you heard okay
she's my secretary I'm my own secretary
my secretary her secretary everybody but
I do a lot of I do I do all the support
work to make sure she's eating I make
sure things get fixed I make there I'm
good at that kind of stuff yeah yeah he
does feed me he will like cook and then
I do all the [ __ ] house [ __ ] I'll
[ __ ] fix cars I'll [ __ ] do all
kind stuff yeah
I'll set things up but so it's just kind
of we're trading labor
yeah exact
all right so where was I okay so weird
why am I asking you why you asking I was
like what this whole discussion was
about all right so as I said Richard
Speck was arrested in July 1963 for
forging and cashing a cashier's $44
paycheck $44 how much that like I said
now I'm gonna look at it I'll put it
right down here when I get it the video
like how much $44 is cuz now I'm curious
probably like a [ __ ] ton of money at
night 163 I was probably bad $120 it's
still not a great ya know but I guess if
you work at a grocery store that's
probably about the same as you get out
cuz you know hey hasn't really gone up
all that much yeah
yeah so he stole a bunch of cigarettes
and beer and three dollars in cash
woohoo so he's gonna go like [ __ ]
party with that so he was 21 years old
at the time he gets convicted of forgery
of regular burglary and was sentenced to
three years in prison however he was
paroled after 16 months now only a week
after he was paroled
it's about 2:20 a.m. on January nights
1965
Richard Speck has a 17 inch carving
knife and he approaches a woman in the
parking lot of her apartment building
jumps on her like holds a knife to her
throat like threatens her and [ __ ] like
that
now she starts screaming her [ __ ]
head off and he ran away but so police
came like pretty much immediately and
they found him only a few blocks away
and arrested him now he got convicted of
aggravated assault and was giving out
attempted rape
yeah which well I think they like he
plea bargained down because I think they
actually were gonna charge him with
attempted murder actually okay um but I
think it got plea bargained down yeah so
they just charged him with aggravated
assault
he got a 16-month sentence which you
know nice for jumping out and like
threatening and in those days you don't
have to do about half of it if you had
good good behavior well yeah and what
ended up happening in this case so he
gets the 16-month sentence this is
supposed to run concurrently with the
parole violation sentence because like I
said he was still on parole at this
point but there was a clerical error and
he
released on July 2nd 1965 so we only
ended up serving like six months and
then he got back out again now here's
something that's kind of interesting and
biography you know like on A&E or
whatever it is they have that show
biography and I watched the biography
episode that they had about Richard
Speck and they interviewed this guy who
had hung out with him when he was who
would hung out with Richard Speck when
he was in his 20s and he just said the
weirdest thing he said you know they
would like him and his buddies and
Richard Speck would like go around to
bars and like go drinking or whatever
just like his drinking buddies and he
said that one he said that he was scared
of Richard's back because he was you
know always kind of like bragging about
all his violent conquest or whatever and
he says that he straight-up bragged to
them about attacking that woman in
Dallas with the knife and the guy that
they were interviewing I don't know what
his name was but he was just like an old
friend of Speck's I guess and he said
the weirdest thing he just said he said
oh well you know that kind of talk that
was a little out there
our group of friends I was like oh a
little out there you think they might
have been some wild asses and then I
think I'm astounded they might have been
some wild asses bragging about the [ __ ]
that they did you know beatin people's
asses and [ __ ] taking [ __ ] or whatever
and then he shot jumps in with that and
they're like what oh well that's a
little too far but maybe they thought he
was lying yeah I don't know they said
that one thing that he would do is they
would go around to bars and he would
like to take that big-ass knife out and
go this is my insurance policy
yeah right he would say [ __ ] like that
yeah yeah so I did yeah that was let me
say something though to the audience if
you were to actually see this guy he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] he wasn't a little dude he
was six-foot ones who's like yeah but he
was a big dude but his build and
everything was very thin not a powerful
guy and he had like all those acne scars
his face he smirked he's trying to live
on his height he's trying to make his
story off of his high
and you know I've done some tall lanky
guys they whip your ass my [ __ ]
stepbrother was one of them but he was a
natural fighter and he was you know
second degree Taekwondo that he didn't
use he actually just beat your ass
through using instinct really there are
some guys that are tall and lanky like
that they can't hurt you but there's
also a lot of a lot of them that are
fakes yeah they're tall and liking
there's nothing to him yeah I mean you
know they yeah if you have long bones
and not much muscle on it leverage is
not in your favor so their arms are not
very strong you know I've been fooled
before by guys that man think this guy's
gonna be pretty [ __ ] tough and then
just went in there and just annihilated
him well if there's all in skinny like
the eyes are up here the eyes are the
eyes are up here so you assume that
there's gonna be physical power involved
but then once you start slinging the
[ __ ] around there's no weight there's
no matter scarecrow yeah and like you
said I think it's easier for like
shorter people like myself to maintain
balance because we're closer to the well
if you put us we don't hurt ourselves as
much when we fall because we don't have
as far to fall
if you put 3 pounds of muscle on a
little short bone ok versus 3 pounds of
muscle on a very long bone yeah leverage
is not in your damage yeah advantage
yeah okay I mean if you look at some of
these power lifters and some his
bodybuilders you know like Lee Priest
Lee Priest is 5 foot 4 you know mr.
Olympia definitely an inch taller than
me yeah and he [ __ ] weighs 200
something pounds and that dude can curl
like [ __ ] I've got what it was 307
pounds which is more than a taller guy
yeah but I just I don't really remember
the numbers offhand I'm kind of drunk
too Lee Priest could basically rip
through the side of a car all right and
he's 5 for like a gorilla like I said
you know I don't think height is a very
good judge of No
you know I mean no it's not it's not
gonna be like oh that dudes short or
that dudes well you take another guy
who's 6
one but he weighs 200 something pounds
and he's took a highly conditioned
muscle then yeah maybe he can be very
[ __ ] strong
it's just that height is not and because
you know a tall guy it's a bigger
skeleton so you can put more muscle on
it but we're always talking about when
you start talking about extremes like
that you're also having to throw in
steroids because the only way to get the
maximum amount of muscle on those kind
of frames is to use steroids if you're
not on steroids then you don't have the
maximum amount yeah that's why steroids
are being used you know there's a normal
limit and then there's a [ __ ]
abnormal limit and most these
bodybuilders are dealing with the
abnormal limit well like I said why
wouldn't they because they're not human
they're superhuman yeah particularly if
you're competing yeah I can't give every
if one person does that everybody has to
lie because that guy would always win
and Lee Priest will tell you that oh
yeah he's on gear you know he's [ __ ]
roid it out well like I said I'm sure
all the competitive ones are just have
to be like yeah their team is that they
all have to do it their testosterone
counts are ten times that of a [ __ ]
immortal male yeah yeah that's why you
gonna bite him in the ass later on down
the line though oh they can live a long
life they can live a very long life they
can live into their 70s depends on what
they're taking it's just that man why
would you want they're doing it for
business mr. universe it's basically a
[ __ ] beauty pageant it's not a sport
it's like mr. America and mr. mr. mrs.
universe the thing about it too is they
click you know I'm all for like people
having their own dreams and goals and
like man you do you whatever but it's
not like you could just walk up to a
random person on the street and go who's
the reigning mr. universe nobody knows
yeah are mr. reinigen who's the reigning
Miss America yeah well it's a cup
they're doing it for each other and I
totally understand it
I told me I get that I totally
understand it's kinda like hot rodding
yeah yeah I mean hot rodders might know
other [ __ ] for yourself it's in your
their hot rodding their own bodies yeah
you know and they haven't had it yeah I
get it
the thing is is that you know yeah I
work out you know I lift regular people
you know I'm I'm on D load we know right
now I would I would never take I would
never take gear because my goals are
to be superhuman I just want to be you
know I mean that well bill yeah and and
and to age well about health more
anything I like I said that's a good and
that's a really reasonable right but
honestly I would never tell anybody else
like I said I know people get like
really judgmental about like other
people's like body moderation I am like
mom I'm for it
as long as you're not hurting anyone
else yeah it's your [ __ ] body dig I
want freaky ass men and women they got
freaky you know like Lee Priest is he's
freaky he's five four
he doesn't look good in clothes he looks
good without clothes yeah because you
can see all the muscles with clothes it
looks like a [ __ ] Oompa Loompa okay
and the same thing you know [ __ ]
there's a freaky old [ __ ] German porn
star [ __ ] Penelope black diamond
who's [ __ ] skinny as hell gigantic
implants you guys can look her up she
looks good without clothes put her in
clothes you look funny probably I would
imagine it would be very and some people
get mad when they see that kind of [ __ ]
but you ever seen me and Jenny come from
where we're like yeah okay we're not
we're not we're very into the goth scene
you know with which is fetish adjacent
and we know porn stars oh we've known we
know people that do porn we knew able to
do fetish porn yeah um so we know what
they're like yeah like I said and most
of them are perfectly they're bus people
yeah they're regular none of them are
crazy
nothing like that they're perfectly
normal when you talk to them most of
they have a [ __ ] very good sense of
humor they do they don't taking that
[ __ ] seriously no yeah so like I said I
have a very like laissez-faire kind of
as long as you're not hurting others
yeah if it's your body if you want to I
mean you know obviously there are limits
to that like if you're killing yourself
or whatever and you don't know you're
doing that yeah but other than that I
don't so like you know you know those
people that like oh I want to be a
leopard and they get tattoos all over in
like their tongue and so I see you know
what I mean it's like people get all
judgmental about it I'm like man
whatever that's yeah it's not wise
though it's not what I would do but yeah
the guy that wanted to be a lion became
a lion and then killed himself
yeah I mean like I said I do think they
have underlying issues as I said there's
always like some limit to it and I think
like a lot of women too that have
extensive plastic surgery
anybody that has extensive plastic
surgery obviously they have some body
issues and so I do think that that
should be dealt yes but you know that
said I do think up to a certain point
you should and some if some body
builders have body dysmorphia oh yes
obvious it's our god man a reckoner
manorexia but some of them dunk a lot of
them dumb you know but you can you can
tell who does well it's very similar
well they have similar like because I
have um I'm not saying it is but um I
have a family member who was anorexic in
her teenage years so uh I you know so I
know what it's like to go through that
and to know somebody that is going
through that and I feel like the same
justifications that they give from not
eating is the same justifications that
the men give but it's just like a
different outcome
yeah but it's the same it seems like the
same disorder it probably is because a
lot of times there it's very nitpicky
yeah well but it's like I said they feel
like they're never big enough where as
anorexic it's you know it's usually
women but you know men are affected by
it too but anorexia they they always
feel like they look fat yeah even though
even if they weigh 60 pounds I look at
the biggest of the [ __ ] guys who
roided-out and the biggest of the
natural bodybuilders and I don't see a
huge difference I look at the big
natural guys and I go yeah that's good
enough yeah I can't look at that and go
no that's not good enough
yeah I mean I don't know what the ROI
what gear dupper what it is and you know
the the stuff fine anorexia it's a
control issue it's usually like I said
it's it's usually girls but more men are
affected by it nowadays but it's usually
girls that don't that feel like they
don't have a lot of control on other
aspects of their lives so they feel like
what they eat and what they look like is
the only
they can't control so they will control
that to a nama to a pathological degree
you know we know ones are like that yeah
oh yeah even by name but we're not going
to but like I said I mean I I grew up
like some one of my families had that
and had to be hospitalized for it
because she would have died but and I
remember going through that because I
was only a couple years younger yeah and
but it's the same justification they
feel like that they feel like they're
never good enough that they you know
don't have any control and for anything
and that's the only thing they control
they can control is what they put in
their body and what their body looks
like and it's also body dysmorphia in
the sense that they have a warped sense
of what they look like they look in the
mirror and they see fat even when there
is none right everyone can weigh 70
pounds and they didn't get well that's
what I mean and like I said I mean she
got down to I think 58 pounds and she's
quite tall um so she I mean she
basically looks like a skeleton but she
still thought she looked fat yeah um you
know so it's not good obviously they
they have a very delusional like sense
of what they look like
yeah dennis is getting pissed get back
to this is getting pissed jacket elbows
I can tell by the back of his head he's
getting pissed the back of his little
Bob I mean you're the one that goes off
on the tangent yeah I don't mind going
off on tangents no tronic I said it's
you know people seem to like the longer
shows and it's like even if we don't
have cuz we're only doing one topic
today so it's not like we have lecture
time should talk about it's like if you
want to go true what time is if you want
to complain about it then they'll then
I'll just delete it no time and uh
actually we're at 54 minutes do you want
to take a break see yeah okay great all
right so we're gonna take a break right
now when we come back we will talk more
about Richards back about all his other
crimes and about the crimes that ended
up making him famous all that I will
never be as famous as me never okay
dennis is feeling a little left out all
right so we'll be back in just a few
minutes
you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
baby's case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
but we are going to visit baby cookie in
her little house how are you doing how
are you doing
do you have anything to say to the
people and my bothering you yeah like
this leave okay that's her top floor
apartment one of her favorite places
I'm Beijing what are you doing okay what
happened what happened being pretty
princess princess fluff ass that's what
I call her because she clearly does not
want people I guess what do you think
about that cookie Beijing just ran right
away I know I don't know what to say
about it
neither do you clearly conspiratorial
podcasts proudly presents the strange
realities conference injury
come join us for one day of
presentations on the paranormal of live
music at night featuring to the north of
rise and fall of the Flat Earth theory
Joshua Cochin alien hybrid lore Jodha
mari pushing the limits of reality
Roswell 1947 what really happened
Timothy Brenner Pennsylvania Wildman and
added to the lineup Marc Anthony Wyatt
Cornish legends and UFO sighting Zach
hunt presentation of this book unwrapped
followed by a live recording of the
conspiratorial podcast more speakers and
music acts to be announced October 19
2019 as I our nationís info at WWE at
ease conference comm $40 at the door 30
bucks presale
[Music]
all right we are back for the second
half of the show
here's Dennis he's still wouldn't yes
the second time we started because the
first time Pookie walked across the
computer seriously we were like a minute
and a half and baby cookie just walked
right across yeah we're done all the
buttons so I don't know if she like
pushed some [ __ ] that liked it so I said
well I'm just gonna start over right
such a troublemaker she's just mad that
we're not paying attention all right so
what made last left Richard Speck he had
just been released from prison
following his aggravated assault charge
against the woman that he jumped on in
the parking lot and pulled a knife on
her and whatnot now he actually managed
to get a job cuz I guess back in the old
days it didn't check your [ __ ] police
records or anything like that so he get
the job as a truck driver for the
Paterson at night company top-down
tearing [ __ ] up
hey you doing get out of there that's
right yeah she'll do that for five
seconds yes she'll be like are they not
looking anymore
yeah I'm gonna go back to now in the
three months that Richard Speck worked
at the Paterson Meat Company he had six
count'em six accidents with his truck
and then finally they were like drunk
you know not only a drunk but he would
not only would he drink but he would
also like drink a whole bunch and then
take like a whole bunch of pills on top
of it
how did like I don't understand how
people like that even function they must
like get used to it after like I
seriously I have like three four drinks
and I don't remember [ __ ] but you know
what I mean so it's like these people
that are like oh yeah I drink like a
[ __ ] whole fish and then like took a
big handful of whatever and they're like
how the [ __ ] are you still walking
around man
guess it depends on how young you are
we're back in the Army every now and
then we'd go on a [ __ ] bender and
drink a fifth like that and then wake up
the next morning at 4:30 in the morning
go run five miles and by the time the
brothers over we were sober yeah but
maybe yeah I could probably do that but
there would be a lot of barfing involved
and also like I said I wouldn't worry
or anything because after a certain
amount of drinks just like my memory
just blacked out so he's had like six
accidents in the truck and finally like
the Patterson become he's like yeah like
we don't think you should be working
here anymore and they fired him now in
December of 1965 at this point speck had
separated from his wife because she had
had enough of his crap obvious right now
his mom recommended it's like well why
don't you like move in with this woman
that was she was the bartender at this
tavern that he always hung out at called
I think it was called Ginny's lounge and
she was an ex-professional wrestler
actually she was 29 years old at the
time and she needed somebody to like
live in and like babysit her kids while
she was working yeah
how'd this go well it honestly it
probably didn't get home because I don't
think it last all that long okay so his
mom was like wanting to just move in
with her and like you know you can watch
her kids and like make a little bit of
money and [ __ ] like that
now not too long after this arrangement
was made I think was only like three
weeks or a month or something like that
um Richard specks wife formally filed
for divorce and this obviously pissed
him off a great deal this same month
which was January of 1966 as I said
Richard Speck got into a knife fight at
the same bar where the bartender worked
at Jenny's lounge and he actually
stabbed a dude and got charged again
with aggravated assault but his mom
intervened and hired a defense attorney
and this defense attorney was able to
get the charge reduced to disturbing the
peace so now this is a hallmark of a lot
of Richard specks like criminal career
he pretty much had every chance his mom
for whatever reason seemed to love him
unconditionally every time he got into
trouble she would help him out she would
bail him out and all his siblings would
do that too like they just helped him
out obviously they gave him money they
found him jobs and [ __ ] like that ever I
don't know and it's just like never
it was never enough for him I guess it's
like guilty for what he went through
when he was a kid maybe oh there's like
I said a lot of people have shitty
stepparents a lot of people have to move
when they're kids not all of them end up
doing what he did so it was just just
these particular individuals I guess so
like I said that's why I think there's
definitely there's they're not all the
same we're all there there's definitely
a genetic component you ought you
obviously have to have a you know kind
of like a pre-existing you know
propensity for that type of behavior
because a lot of people go through some
[ __ ] when their kids and they turn out
perfectly though today today is [ __ ]
common culture you know and the media
promotes the ideas that we're all the
same we're always saying do they yeah
that's what's coming we're all the same
but we're not all the same people are
different we're all individuals and you
know people do [ __ ] weird [ __ ] based
upon their individuality yeah that's the
way it is well like I said I never got
that I never got the feeling that anyone
was saying we were all the same
obviously everyone's different and
that's and and honestly that's why
that's why I think that it's important
to like kind of look into this kind of
[ __ ] because I think that serial killers
in particular mass murders in particular
they kind of have this thing it's like
oh what they're looking for one thing to
like pin on it to make sense of why this
person behaved as they behaved but I
think there's a lot of other [ __ ] going
on too because like I said I mean
Richard Speck up until he was six years
old
seemed to have a pretty idyllic life
like I said he wasn't the brightest kid
he wasn't like you know they didn't have
a lot of money or anything like that but
he had a normal childhood
and then yeah he had a shitty stepdad
yeah he you know didn't do so good in
school yeah he had to move to another
lot of people have gone through a lot
worship than that and didn't become mass
murderers or serial killers so obviously
he had you know a propensity for that
anyway like genetically it has to be
that it has to be like a combination of
those two things
hey stop tearing up paper she pulled
paper out of the damn bookcase
oh my god stop it
okay man she was getting all kind of
trouble today so as I said his mom was
able to get the charge reduced to
disturbing the peace so Richards back
only paid a $10 fine which like I said I
have to look up how like how much that
is in today's money it's probably a lot
more than it sounds like he got put in
jail for three days because he didn't
pay the fine now this was actually the
last time that Richard Speck was in
police custody in Dallas now in March of
1966
Richard Speck buys this old beat-up car
it was actually a 12 year old car now
this was what I was thinking of before
where he actually burglarized a grocery
store
he stole 70 cartons of cigarettes and
then started selling them out of the
trunk of his car yes a grocery store
parking lot okay well he had 70 cartons
yeah so if he sold him for two or three
dollars a piece that's a lot of money
yeah back in those days right now I'm
not really sure how many packets of
cigarettes he sold out of the trunk of
his car and the parking I saw him buy
the car but I'm imagining he sold them
all because then he abandoned this a car
in the parking lot however since he was
the dumbass that bought the car the car
could be traced back to him right which
maybe he didn't think of I don't know so
the police actually were able to trace
him because the car was in his name they
issued a warrant for his arrest for
burglary now he was actually arrested in
Dallas this would be his forty second
arrest
damn and he if if convicted he would
obviously go to prison again for a very
long time so his sister Carolyn like I
said his mom and his siblings were all
very adamant about helping him out
whenever he needed help
even though he - oh yeah yeah that's a
dirt bag yeah I mean some of it was like
minor [ __ ] right but but that doesn't
happen to a normal person right it's
like I can see maybe one or two times
like you know Oh like like drunken
disorderly
right something like that like PB
everage per day the average person goes
their whole life without being arrested
right I feel like I feel like I have
never been arrested but you know what I
mean I've got tickets and [ __ ] obviously
but I've never been arrested now arrest
and conviction the average person never
has it happened - right
so yeah 42 little excessive I'm just
saying you were asking for trouble
that's the only way yeah well that's
what I mean and like I said I feel like
he fancied himself something of oh I'm a
criminal badass you know I mean cuz he
got that whole tattoo that said born to
raise hell like on his [ __ ] arm back
when getting tattoos was the sign of a
badass
well yeah cuz now you got cute girls
it's now everybody's yeah little Hello
Kitty tattoos and [ __ ] everybody's gotta
[ __ ] yeah stereotypical crap now yeah so
because he would probably get a really
bad prison term because he had been
arrested so many times
his sister Carolyn you know like I said
and his family was always like willing
to help him out even though he was
always getting into trouble and it must
been a pain they asked for them to
constantly have to bail his stupid ass
out um his sister Carolyn drives him to
the Dallas bus depot and his like get
the [ __ ] out of here so he goes to
Chicago now in Chicago he actually
stayed with his older sister Martha who
lived there with her husband and her
kids and whatever now from there he
stayed with her for a while and then he
moves back to his hometown of Monmouth
Illinois and he stayed with some family
friends now he had a brother named
Howard who was a carpenter in Monmouth
and as I said his brother was like very
willings like hey I'll get you a job so
he [ __ ] got him a job like sanding
plasterboard for a different carpenter
so like I said this dude had every
opportunity people were like giving him
jobs left and right but right about this
time he seemed like he was doing okay
for a little bit but then right about
this time he found out that his ex-wife
who as I said you know he was like going
to prostitutes and being like hey I got
a prostitute even though you're pregnant
you know what I mean he was doing that
kind of [ __ ] and thought that he was
cheating on her you know that she was
cheating on him the whole time he found
out that she had remarried and she had
actually remarried only two days after
the divorce from him was finalized she
had something lined up well the divorce
takes a long time to finalize right yeah
I know I've been through that [ __ ] but
yeah so it takes a long time so she was
just waiting for the divorce to be final
so she could marry her new guy and that
seemed to really really piss him off
because even though cuz he didn't have
anything waiting on him I guess and like
I said even though he felt like well I
can just like cheat on you as much as I
want but it's like even though she had
left him even though she was separate
even though she had divorced him and he
had presumably signed the divorce papers
I'm not sure how it worked back then but
somehow her marrying someone else
yeah that was just a step too far that
was a betrayal of him like she was never
allowed to like he's a control freak
yeah clearly so that apparently made him
very very upset so in March of 1966 he
moves to the Christie hotel in downtown
bond mouth and spent pretty much several
days just going from bar to bar and just
like getting completely shit-faced now
around this time he's like.he there was
another incident where he was in a bar
in Gulfport Illinois and he got detained
overnight because he had threatened
another guy like in the bar bathroom
with a knife so he gets arrested again
for that now in April 3rd of 1966 he
broke into the house of a 65 year old
woman named mrs. Virgil Harris now she
had been out but she came home at about
one o'clock in the morning and found him
in her house and he was a brandished a
knife at her and basically tied her up
raped her and ransacked her house she
had been out babysitting actually and he
stole the $2.50 that she had earned
babysitting so he raced a 65 year old
woman yeah
it's not nice yeah so she gave a
description to the police she said he's
about a six foot tall white man she said
he was very polite and he had a very
soft voice with a southern drawl
now this was like kind of significant
because I mean this was Illinois not a
lot of people have Southern drawl zin
Illinois but he had lived in Texas for
so long that I guess he had developed
that boy or it was a put-on or something
like that so it stood out you know to me
he sounded like [ __ ] Johnny Cash hmm
yeah yeah so when you're talking about
Illinois I was like yeah but he sounded
like a southerner yeah I mean he's gotta
win taxes for a little wild or you know
for a significant chunk of his youth I
guess he lived in Texas and what you
doing
it's just dropping water oh I bet you
were like presenting it like no sir drop
water pissing on myself or some drops
hitting in [ __ ] it's all the damn ice
well we need a lot of ice this is laura
de although it is starting to cool off
slightly
yeah just starting to itch it's going
down to like 85 and yes
105 and it's not as humid as it was the
oppression is not in here is nice and
cool I mean it was it actually reached
71 degrees inside that my
air-conditioned garage nice yeah cuz the
air conditioner went off that window
unit is air conditioning like what 74 71
71 but it can't maintain it all the time
on a really hot day we we have gone
through have a long a bit later this
house eight or nine years we've gone
through two different yeah they just
can't they can't handle it even with
central air they can't handle it you
could put you put the thermostat on 71
and on a really hot day it just it's
about like 75 it won't make it you can't
you can't even in Florida they're not
built they're just not built for that
they're not built to work that hard it's
sad but that's how hot it is done Ariel
yes so as I said he's he's raped and
robbed a 65 year old woman so clearly
this guy has no shame now a week after
that incident you say 65 or 75 65
okay yeah he broken her house while she
was out babysitting yeah but look at
when you look at the guy you underst you
know this guy is not a catch
yeah I mean well it was not he's not you
know this guy's hurt he asked me I guess
it's like the thing is he had real bad
skin like it looked like he had really
bad acne as a kid and like his standards
were very low I guess so yeah but I mean
if I don't know like if when he was
young he wasn't terrible looking if he
had like a good personality then he
probably could have overcome that well
that's kind of like a universal thing
but because yeah he was a scumbag
and he looked like that so I don't you
sure that didn't help as long as you're
a healthy guy you're not too far out of
shape you don't know meaning if you can
talk you can get a girl that's what I
mean it doesn't like and we've met
before right women in general despite
the stereotype women in general are not
as shallow and will if a guy better no
I'm just saying I'm well you know that's
that's a term that amends men are far
optically stimulated you women aren't as
much not as much they're not as much so
women say well it's shallow you know to
be optically stimulated me a very
primitive sexual apparatus yeah they
want to hump on things that look good
that's really it's that's how [ __ ]
simple it is you know I mean it's
something that we've inherited through
through other more primitive creatures
cuz our [ __ ] [ __ ] asses are only
designed to [ __ ] spread seed if it
looks good it must be good and try to
get as much as that out there as you can
that's that's the strategy that [ __ ]
rose to the top when it came to yeah
male animals of all species well and
since women have have different
standards block out to [ __ ] bags and
choose the ones that can actually have
been practical concerns right because we
have a lot more to lose it's more
expensive to raise
even in the wild so you have to choose
you have to choose the male that will
invest in you yeah
if he doesn't invest in you then you
[ __ ] bypass that one yeah so it's not
about shallowness because you're passing
a moral judgment on animal behavior and
no matter what people want to [ __ ]
say humans are animals they're just one
of the they're just one of the animals
in the animal kingdom
we're prime e yeah we are sentient but
as I've gotten older I believe that
there are many animals that are sent it
I think I've seen it in a lot of other
animals I think animals in several
animals are a lot smarter than their
yeah they all most animals mammals seem
to be at least operating at a child
level yeah I think most of them do so
it's just the way life is you know I
mean life is not about what's right or
wrong it's just about what works and
that's what works and these animals yeah
but like I said so if this - like this
dude's looks like I said he wasn't like
a mutant or anything like that yeah he
had bad skin but a lot of people do it's
like he you know so if he had been like
a cool dude like if he was funny or
sweet or you know had some other thing
to offer that made money then I don't
think that he would have had any trouble
but because he was also a creep you know
to keep to keep it real for you men out
there if you're young and cute you can
get some tail alright if you're not
young and cute you and you're old you
better be rich that's the - survival
strategy not just rich you [ __ ] you need
to have something else - yeah yeah
necessarily hobby money not just rich
it's just you well the guys that are
rich hat usually have certain traits
right that kind of I mean and like it's
not a promote when the attraction from
women because guys that have a lot of
money and their or older have success
and status
women love status but for men for an
older kind of have status he is a
certain way
that's how that status accrued to him
well yeah that's what I mean it's that's
why I feel like it's bad to say this Oh
women only want people that have money
or people that you know like status no
it's not just that either it's that you
don't want another person that you have
to take care of that doesn't you don't
just want some bomb that's gonna lay out
on your couch that goes not make any
money and not help you around the house
feel the same and not that's what I mean
you just still like that you know that
not somebody that's nice ranked you down
a high-status man is successful right
and a high state he's successful in his
own right not depending zag you and a
high-status man is successful for
certain reasons yes and it's usually he
has a certain personality for it he has
certain skills for it so that makes it
conducive to a relationship yeah because
like I said you just you just you don't
want you can't have relationships you
never become successful yeah because the
women that are dating this successful
guy he also has certain attributes that
make him successful with men that's how
he got successful yeah it's just a you
know I mean it's just study [ __ ]
wealthy and powerful men okay they're
just guys idiot here's a real common one
here's a real common one that you people
can relate to Sylvester Stallone he's a
successful guy men like him women like
him he has a lot of money he has a very
young wife right now okay if you look at
way he is it makes sense he's very
artistic he's intelligent well yeah he's
a writer he's a writer
he keeps good he takes care of himself
you know he's just a guys like that are
gonna be successful that's just what it
is well like I said and it this kind of
applies for anybody men are women you
just have something you have to have
something to offer the other right those
you don't have anything to offer the
other person right no one's gonna want
to like anyway and really you don't have
thing to offer other people into your
cool so that's really kind of the reason
why sly is successful cuz he was cool
that's really the [ __ ] was cool he was
intelligent and that's the really the
crux of the matter as he got over he
knew how to play that game and you say
that was a good way to just have it yeah
and like I said there's a lot of ways
that a guy could be quite a bit
successful so like I said that's why I
don't mighty boosh shimmy his [ __ ] is
successful at David and Natalie I love
Steve and that's not something really
sexy about not classically good-looking
guy no he's not very attractive he's
very attractive because his personality
was very appealing
he's cool that's and that's what I'm
saying it's like if you look at like you
know actors or other successful people
that I admire rough it's not because of
what they look like yeah it's because of
what they've done and I'm not saying
Steve Buscemi looks bad he's a skinny
guys a thin guy and he knows he's not
ugly he's just weird looking guys I'm
looking and but the thing is that's
Buscemi yeah and he owns it right that's
what I think matters he's a magnetic
person so and he has like a cool person
out and like he you know the way he
comes across in his movie at all that's
really cool it all boils down to [ __ ]
character yeah really that's really
weird at all and I think it's more
important it's honestly I think it's
more important like because honestly I
don't think with character everything
else just [ __ ] everything else is not
is secondary like I said you can look
like anything you can weigh 500 pounds
you can like [ __ ] anything you can
look like Steve Buscemi you can look
right if you were fat guys then [ __ ]
right if you're a cool guys were funny
if you're sweet if you like have like a
really good personality then no one will
care what you look like seriously and if
you own it don't like this don't be like
[ __ ] you know don't be all like
insecure about it don't be like yeah
this is badass Chris Farley had
good-looking women you know just
remember him cuz he was funny
he was funny of course he died brilliant
yeah that wasn't drug abuse though that
was that was you guys don't do that yeah
so anyway returning to Richard's back
yeah about a week after he raped and
robbed
65 year-old woman like ass like a winner
yeah yeah now at that time there was a
32 year old barmaid and she worked at a
place called Frank's place a bar in
downtown Monmouth now she was last seen
leaving this tavern where she worked at
12:45 a.m. on April 9th and was reported
missing April 13th
her body was found later that day in a
hog house behind the tavern she had
actually died from a blow to the abdomen
that had ruptured her liver now
interestingly Richard Speck was a
regular customer of Frank's place and
the hog house where her body was found
was one of many that he had helped build
in one of the places that he had worked
so Richard Speck got questioned about
this murder so because he turned up to
like collect his last paycheck from this
sound suspicious that's what I mean okay
now so the police questioned him at
first about this murder and then they
said well you need to like stay in Tay
you can't leave town you know because
you're still a suspect so police came
back a couple days later to question him
further like to the Christie hotel where
he had been staying and they discovered
that he had left the hotel on the
pretense that he was just going to do
some laundry and that he had [ __ ]
taken off so many people suspect that
this was actually his first murder damn
though that's weird he was very famous
for his later ones but this was one that
was unsolved that seems like his MO
because if you're trying to kill
somebody though why do you hit him in
the abdomen because I should say that
the the murders later than the student
nurse murders that made him famous one
of the victims had also been kicked in
the stomach okay in a similar fashion
anybody could kill somebody by kicking
him in the stomach well it depends on
how hard you can imagine how slightly
built they are I mean there's a lot of
you know just take a long
time to die from that though yeah that's
what's horrifying about but wouldn't
they go look for help who know I don't
know that just sounds off that just
sounds off he never admitted to that one
though right not that I know of hmm he
didn't talk a lot though I mean he did
talk to him and I'll get into this a
little bit later but he did talk to
those two guys that were like you know
in the nascent FBI behavioral sciences
unit but they thought that he didn't
have much insight about sound x maybe he
jumped up and down on her
were there any was there any other
damage to her I'm not really sure but
they said that's what the cause of death
was her her liver was I'd have to see
Eddie to see the autopsy report that
sounds like an accident maybe he didn't
have anything to do with that I don't
know or maybe he did right there there
maybe he didn't kill her but he killed
her by accident too
yeah and then didn't admit to it I don't
know I kind of doubt that I think he
kind of kicking somebody in the stomach
though that's on purpose like I said if
you kick them enough times if you have
like a what if you have like a
steel-toed boot on and you just feel
like Kevin what if she was unconscious
and you just kept kicking her don't
steel-toe boot thing I don't think makes
a big difference
I've on steel toed boots it doesn't
really matter if there's a steel toe in
it or not it's still same mass hitting
you I'm just saying what if she was
unconscious and he just got a beer maybe
but yeah but you would think that if you
were trying to kill somebody you would
strangle them or beat him in the head
who knows I'm just saying you weren't
you died it is and they found her body
later on suspiciously in a place that he
had worked on not that far from where he
was staying at the time they also and he
also skipped town like right after they
questioned him so that seems a little
fishy yeah also they searched his hotel
room after they found out that he was
gone and they found a bunch of [ __ ] from
mrs. Virgil Harris's apartment who was
the 65 year old woman that he had raped
and robbed her place so he found like
they found like a bunch of her [ __ ] in
his hotel room also if he did a bunch of
other [ __ ] from other burglaries that
they think that he had pulled off it if
he did kill her I think he maybe killed
her by accident he was trying to get
something off of her get some sex offers
no a fight broke out he kicked her in
the stomach she didn't react well to
that started stumbling around and she
did die he's like [ __ ] it I'm out of
here because trying to kill somebody
usually you're gonna do something like
beat him in the head until they're dead
instantly
yeah stab them something that it just
sounds kind of if that sounds like a
strange case there it does but I
definitely think he was responsible for
that [ __ ] whether he is or accidental I
don't think it really matters at this
point it's a good chance he was
responsible yeah yeah the [ __ ] he did
later on right I'm really not yet not
willing to give him the benefit of the
doubt that might have been that might
have been an introductory thing yeah and
then you like God it was just like yeah
okay it's not as it's not as it's easy
you know I mean yeah you know it's
easier to kill people let's do it this
continue to do it yeah maybe just like
that so after he skipped out after that
crime in April of 1966 April 19th 1966
he goes back to stay with his sister
Martha like I said his family were
always willing to like help him out and
take him back in and [ __ ] like that now
this was in the north west side of
Chicago she lived there with her husband
Jean and they had two teenage daughters
Martha had previously been a pediatric
nurse and Jean was a railroad switchman
who worked at night now when Richard
Speck turned up on their doorstep you
know saying that he needed a place to
stay and he needed help and stuff like
that his whole story about why he had to
leave Mon mouth was that oh well there
was a crime syndicate there and they
were trying to make me sell drugs and I
didn't want to so I had to like a likely
store and his sister and brother and
were like no I don't think that's the
truth at all but they figured since he
was already [ __ ] there and they had to
do something with him Jean the husband
had actually been in the Navy and he
thought well maybe we can get him a job
with like the Merchant Marine like you
know maybe he'll and then he'll be out
on a ship and he'll be out of our face
and that would be really good so he
takes Richards back to the US Coast
Guard office to get like the
letter that you have to get to work as
an apprentice seaman to like get put on
various ships now with this at this
stage like the application he had to get
fingerprinted he had to get photographed
he had a physical examination he had all
that so all that was completed and he
got a letter of authority now he
actually got a berth on a on a ship
called the Clarence B Randall it was a
Lake freighter and there was 33 crew
members on it so he got put on this ship
and he was doing okay for a little while
but then like one day when he was on
there he apparently like doubled over in
pain and they had a take him to a
hospital and it he had acute
appendicitis so they had to like
emergency like a remove his appendix or
he would have died which many of the
doctors there said now while he was in
the hospital they took him to a hospital
in Hancock Michigan and he had to stay
there for two weeks like recovering from
the surgery now while he was there he
had like all these kind of nurses like
waiting on him and stuff like that and
some people have speculated that it was
this time period that kind of made him
fixate on nurses because they were all
like very nice to him and they were all
taking care of him and paying attention
and stuff like that so that might have
like you know contributed to the [ __ ]
that happened later on so he gets
discharged from the hospital after two
weeks he didn't have a lot of money so
he goes back to stay with his sister
Martha and her family now he apparently
um he had met a woman who was a nurse at
the hospital in Michigan at the time and
her name is Judy Lacan nimi she was 28
years old now the weird thing about this
is that him and her dated for like two
weeks and she had nothing but good
things to say about him she said he was
a complete and total gentleman it's like
he took her out like to expensive
dinners he took her out dancing he took
her like he was like a super nice guy
and like she couldn't understand like
what had happened later trying to start
to start a new leaf I guess so and they
said that was like the only time but she
never had any complaints about her I
mean they know they didn't like know
each other that long
but it's like that seems really [ __ ]
strange but yes that was that whole
thing so March 20th he gets back on the
crew of the Clarence B Randall you know
where he had had to leave before because
the appendicitis now a couple a little
while after he gets back on the ship he
started getting into a lot of trouble
again he was like drinking taking pills
[ __ ] like that he got into like [ __ ]
fights with the officers on the boat he
fell off the boat a couple of times like
in a drunken stupor so eventually they
fired him and they kicked him off the
boat so he ends up staying at this
[ __ ] flophouse in Chicago and he's a
loser pretty much and like I said every
opportunity every opportunity is helping
him they're finding him jobs and he
keeps very nothing him money and he just
keeps screwing it up yeah he just keeps
screwing it up so I would think that
there's a certain part of him that
realizes man I'm a [ __ ] loser
yes man yeah I think that's happening I
guess so losing hope yeah I do think
that's an issue I mean this is not a guy
I don't know it just seems like he
didn't really he could have had like a
completely normal if unremarkable life
like I said he wasn't a [ __ ] genius
he had a bunch of self-hate
he might have I mean self-loathing is it
yeah although I do feel like he he
doesn't seem like and I've only seen a
couple of interviews with him but he
doesn't seem like a very introspective
person I do this is very unlike Edie
Kemper who seemed to have at least a
semblance of insight into his behavior
like the psychological you know
ramifications of camera wasn't whoas
mean by the [ __ ] though true but he
was intelligent and he did seem to have
some insight even if it was faked
he did seem to have some insight into
that I think he had some insight but
then he also tried to use that was me
the [ __ ] is that to get what he wants
but like I said that was that was a
hallmark of his intelligence though
because he was very deliberately trying
to manipulate he knew by manipulating
there
you other people had empathy right yeah
I I do I just generally I feel like
Richard Speck is just kind of like a
dumb he's just like a dumb animal yeah
I'm not sure if he could have turned out
differently if his circumstances had
been different I don't think he had the
intelligence I'm not sure that he would
have because I do feel like yeah he had
like some [ __ ] happen when he was a kid
but the [ __ ] that happened to him when
he was a kid was not that bad like
compared to other people who turned out
okay so I feel like just yeah Cheryl was
stupid yeah in this case I feel like
there was nothing that could have been
done because even when he was very young
like a young teenager he had already
started committing petty crime it would
sound like everything was done actually
if you asked me so that's what I mean
and he and like I said it's not like
people words like projected him it's not
like his family were like [ __ ] off we
don't want anything to do with you it's
like he would turn up on their Dorset
they would give him money they would try
to find him said they would try to help
him they tried to help him
just tough until the end typical
psychopath yeah I do feel like he just
didn't feel anything for other people at
all so I don't know if there's anything
that could have been done to help him
because like I said a lot of things were
done to help him and obviously that
didn't really do any man if you gave
that guy everything in the world he'd
still [ __ ] it up yeah I did that's one
thing I feel and like I said I can't say
that about every single word I said like
I said I'm not saying that I sympathize
for these dudes or anything because
obviously they have choices and they
didn't have to do what they did but this
guy I just I don't think that there's
anything that could have been done I
just don't but so after what he did it
his ass beat yeah his ass beat many
stock yeah there's never any inclination
in this any of this information that he
ever had his ass beaten but I'm gonna
say that had his ass been beaten maybe
he would have turned out differently
maybe I don't know I kind of doubt it
sounds like he needed an ass beat I kind
of doubt it that I think he would have
needed more than one because I think he
was kind of he was one of those people
that they used to call incorrigible yeah
like he was just like a delinquent it
seemed like he was just as a lingua
maybe that wouldn't have happened if his
dad hadn't died when he was so young and
if he'd have liked a more positive male
role model may not accept but Janani
I don't know yeah I kind of doubt it I
kind of feel like he would have just
gone this way regardless that he would
have just found some other excuse so all
right so after that um you know the the
girl that he was dating for two weeks
apparently they she you know she was one
of the nurses that took care of him when
he had appendicitis
apparently they parted on good terms she
gave him 80 [ __ ] dollars which was
however much and in modern money part
about two hundred that's probably like a
lot of money so she gave him a lot of
money and then he went on his merry way
and then at the end of June of 1966 his
brother-in-law gene again took him to
the National Maritime Union to find like
another berth on another ship because
he'd been kicked out the first one cuz
like I said these people are just like
going out of their way to help me yeah
help is this out now so while he's at
this the National Maritime Union hiring
hall in Chicago uh while he's there like
getting his new seaman's card or
whatever like looking for postings or
whatever this was only like a block away
from one of these townhouses that was
used to house student nurses from the
South Chicago community hospital which
if you ain't know anything about Richard
Speck you'll know where this is going
so yeah it was only like a block away at
the time it's kind of the story is kind
of forming in my head I know what's
going on good okay good yeah he's
realizing that he's hopeless do you ask
me it really does seem like you come to
the end of his rope a point he knows
he's a [ __ ] yeah yeah and that there's
like no point in continuing 2% it's
almost kind of like suicide what he does
next I think good yeah I get that I get
that idea I get that idea so July 8th
1966 you know gene drives him to the N
mu hiring hall to pick up his seaman's
card he's registering for a berth on a
ship now he thought might that had like
more seniority than him
which was a birth on the SS flying spray
which was going to South Vietnam so he
goes back to Martha's Martha and Jane's
apartment and stays there over the
weekend now by the time Monday comes
around his sister and brother-in-law are
pretty much sick of him just like laying
around the couch and not getting a job
despite all their best efforts so
there's like okay well you have to just
get out of here we will help you one
last time but that's you know we've come
to the end of our rope pretty much so he
packs his bags gene drives him to the
hiring hall you know again it's like you
know just wait and see like maybe they
have a job for you but you can't stay at
our house anymore you're just disrupting
our lives and just laying around our
couch and being a bomb so he waited
around for a little while and didn't get
anything so then he goes and stays at
some rooming house for that night now he
comes back to the hiring hall the next
day and he got an assignment on an oil
tanker which was about a 30-minute drive
away but by the time he gets there his
position has been given to someone else
because I guess he took too long or
whatever so then he drives back to
Chicago and finds out that the NMU Hall
is now closed so he can't get in
position that day now he didn't have
enough money for to like to stay
anywhere that night so he ended up like
squatting in like an abandoned house or
whatever now he basically then goes to
back to Martha and Jean who were finally
just like okay well I'm sorry you didn't
get anything blah blah
he's waiting again in front of the NMU
hiring hall his sister finally gives him
$25 and it's like just please get out of
our faces we're just like pretty much
sick of dealing with you so at this
point
Richard Speck thinks oh well I have 25
bucks which like I said but I guess was
a lot of money back then
so he's like why bother waiting around
for work because I have $25 I'm just
gonna go and [ __ ] drink on this [ __ ]
yeah so he just proceeds to a tavern
that's a little way down the street and
just pretty much drinks all day now at
this point okay
so what he ended up doing this day like
before the crime that he is best known
for occurred he actually spends this
whole entire day drinking in taverns now
not only that but he has also started
following this woman named Ella Mae
Hooper who was 53 years old and she had
also been going bar to bar you know
because obviously she's made some
terrible life choices so she's been like
going from bar to bar so he's following
her like all day like she'll go to the
next bar he'll go to the next bar you
know what I mean
now at some point he confronts her and
forces her at knifepoint to go to his
room he was staying at a room at the
shipyard in raped her and stole the 22
caliber revolver out of her purse hmm so
then he goes back to drink at another
tavern she didn't go the cops I don't
know if she did or not right but yeah so
yeah he raped her and stole her gun so
then he goes back to his room at about
10:30 p.m. puts on an entirely black
outfit gets his pocket knife a
switchblade and the gun that he had just
stolen from the woman that he had
accosted and walks a mile and a half
west to the nurses townhouse at 231 9 a
hundred Street now this was a townhouse
that was used as sort of like a
dormitory for a like student nurses they
were going through there you know
they're their last thing like before
they were becoming nurses so a lot of
them would stay like two or four to a
room or whatever and it was you know
like like I said kind of like a
dormitory now it kind of differs like it
seems like he broke into the apartment
building itself by using the pocket
knife to like pry open the window and
then like he climbed in and then
apparently he goes to the door of this
random apartment and he knocks on it and
when one of the women answered the door
he pretty much flashed a gun in her face
and said I'm coming in now at this stage
he later claimed that he was like so
high on drugs and so drunk that he
didn't remember what
but I don't know I'm kind of down I
don't believe that is yeah he can he can
pry his way through a [ __ ] window
yeah yeah I wouldn't give a [ __ ] what I
mean yeah yeah yeah so not on that he's
hell-bent on what he's doing and he's
not as drunk as he's saying it and like
you said it seems like it just seems
like everything had come to a head at
this point like his sister and
brother-in-law had kicked him out he
wasn't able to get a job after several
days of trying you ask me he's going out
in a blaze of glory that's definitely
what it seemed like I mean it seems like
he just doesn't have any hope that his
life is gonna get any better like I said
and I'm not like making it easy for the
dude but he hasn't had any prime trim
and he knows there's good-looking girls
in there he's gonna get something yeah I
mean he's gonna go kill himself or be
killed by the cops or end up in prison
by all accounts he can't take this [ __ ]
anymore my only company has been
watching this place because like I said
this this whole town house this whole
apartment complex was used by that
College like to house they're roasting
students so he had been kind of watching
they were all in their early 20s so he's
like but like watching out so it's a
prime feeding ground for a rapist and
he's already raped people so yeah that's
all it is he's going out in a blaze of
glory yep that's exactly when rape fast
what year was this 66 19 in season rape
fest 66 that's what he's gonna yeah so
he comes in now all of them weren't like
he ended up actually in the end he
actually ended up killing eight women
that we're all staying in this one
apartment now all of them were not
present when he first came in like some
of them came in like Gloria Davy she
actually came in a little bit later like
after he had already come in and like
kind of tied everyone up and got
everyone subdued she had been out on a
date with her fiance and she came in
later and then he took her kind of
unearthed this the creepy thing about
this is that he was in there for like
four and a half or five hours yeah like
he had them all tied up he was obviously
um you know threatening them with the
gun and saying what he was but for a
long time because one woman did survive
but she was saying for a long time he
just kind of sat
there and smoked and talked to them now
I think what and what ended up happening
was that because the women had been
trained as nurses and they had taken
like a lot of psychology classes and
their whole thing was like you know we
have to like calm people down because
obviously people were like in a lot of
distress so they thought they might be
able to like calm him down or talk him
out of it so they were trying to do that
for like a lot of the time that he was
in there I'm sure he got off on that
though probably this is the same thing
that Bundy did basically yeah I went
into the sorority house yeah yeah he
killed a bunch of them there though did
yeah this is a very similar thing this
is like one night that he did that to it
now what [ __ ] Rich's back ended up
doing was that like I said he had them
all tied up with like strips of
bedsheets and shouldn't like that he
would like take each of them like into
the next room and like rape and kill
them like one by one yeah the other ones
didn't know what he was doing no they
didn't that helped him do what he's had
they had they'd known he was killing
them one by one they would have thought
yeah you know that's the thing and like
the thing about it too is that the first
one he took was this woman named Pamela
Wilkin and like I said they were all in
their early 20s now apparently he takes
her into this room and she did fight him
she spit in his face she said you know I
know what you look like I'm gonna
identify you it was who she was like
really mad bad thing to say and true but
like I said you you can see like why she
would be upset about it now apparently
while he was attacking her two other two
other student nurses who lived in the
apartment came in I think it was Mary
Ann Jordan and Suzanne Farris I think
those were the two that came in so that
kind of like interrupted him like mid
attack so that like made him even
angrier so he ended up pretty much he
didn't rape all of them but he raped a
you know a significant portion of them
but all of them did end up dying he
usually stabbed them or you know
strangled them and did rape them Gloria
Davy actually ended up getting the worst
of it I believe she was the last one
killed she was strangled raped and also
sodomized one of the other women was
also
he actually likes slit her throat so
deeply that she was almost decapitated
so you know like I said this was like a
several hour you know he would take them
into different rooms if you see there's
like a really disturbing like I watched
a [ __ ] documentary about this there's
a really disturbing like little drawing
of the apartment it was a pretty big
place with like a bunch of different
rooms and stuff and they show like where
all the bodies were because he would
take them into like different rims yes
so like I said the girls that were in
the main room they didn't really they
were tied up and they didn't really know
what was going on so I mean I'm sure
they imagined that it was something bad
but I think that initially I'm not sure
if he initially went in there to kill
them I think he just went in there to
rape and robbed them because he did take
all their [ __ ] like he you know one of
the things he did was he went through
all their purses he asked them for all
their money so he did like collect all
their stuff so maybe they thought that
he was just gonna rob them and maybe he
was gonna rape them and then he would
leave so maybe that's why you know what
I mean so maybe that's why they didn't
fight back as much as they might have
maybe he thought he was gonna rape them
and robbed him but I think first one
he's like in his face that's what I mean
I haven't kill these women because
there's too many
there's too many and there's too many
witnesses this was like a lot of this
was like eight or nine women like all in
one room that he's like trying to keep
like you know what I mean - under
control right because you can't control
them all right now significantly as it
happened whether or not I'm not sure if
Richard Speck just couldn't count or if
he didn't know was going out or whatever
but one of the women actually managed to
roll under a bed and she just stayed
under there and she lived well they all
looked the same to him there was a bunch
of them I can just kind of get him and
you know what I mean forget one thing
with he forgot I guess so yeah and like
I said maybe he was [ __ ] high I don't
know
but Wow well yeah he was pretty lucid I
don't think he was as drunk errors I
know him too because he said oh I don't
even write guys an excuse
yeah I think so too because when they
talked to him later he seemed to
remember pretty good yeah you know what
I mean
so while he was in you know in the other
room with
the other victims she just like rolled
under the bed and hoped he wouldn't
notice and he didn't so she actually
survived her name is Corazon Amer ow
it'll be an ogre like this she was yeah
um three or four of whom were Filipino
that was like a pretty common saying a
lot of them were becoming nurses so she
stayed under there uh you know until he
had taken all the other ones into the
other rooms and she didn't really know
what had happened but then like after he
left she rolled out from under the bed
and saw that they were all dead she
opened the window and started screaming
that they were all dead and once
somebody came in like call the police
now police were able to find two
fingerprints in the apartment in the
apartment where the eight women were
killed one was kind of smudged and one
was like more clear they were able to
later match these two Richard's back
because like I said he had a very long
criminal history also the one survivor
of the massacre was able to provide a
very detailed a composite sketch of the
perpetrator to the police which if you
see it looked very much like Richard
Speck really looks now it so happened
that two days after the murders
Richard Speck was actually identified as
the perpetrator by another guy he was a
drifter named Claude Lunsford and he had
been drinking with Richards back at this
apartment at this lake hotel called the
star hotel on West Madison Avenue and
this guy saw a sketch in the paper and
said hey that looks just like Richard's
back so he called the cops now
apparently the cops didn't take this
call all that seriously I don't know why
I don't know if it was just because the
guy was homeless or whatever I don't
think he was homeless but he was just
like living in Hertz at hotels or
whatever now while Richard Speck was
staying in this hotel
however he actually attempted suicide
which goes along with your going out
like a copy of that's how he was yeah he
was just like come to the end of his
rope so he was gonna go out in a blaze
of glory or whatever now he liked birth
look at a bottle and tried to slash his
arms or slash his wrists open with it
now the clerk at the front desk of the
star hotel called in the emergency and
they came and got him and took him to
the hospital
and it so happened that when the surgeon
that was attending to him like wiped
away the blood they saw the tattoo on
his arm that said born to raise hell and
he remembered that
the woman that had survived the nursing
school you know the apartment massacre
had said he had a tattoo that said born
to raise hell on his forearm and so the
police knew where he was he was
obviously in the hospital so they came
and they came and arrested him so now at
the time
Richard Speck said he had no idea what
had happened he couldn't remember
anything about that night I was so drunk
I was so high blind yeah yeah so but
they said that he did while he was at
the cook any hospital that he'd they
said that he did confess the crime to a
doctor there now they wouldn't let the
doctor testify at the ensuing trial
because they said oh well spec was
sedated at the time he made that
confession so it could be questioned
blah-dee-blah but it turned out that
they didn't really need the confession
because they had you know the woman that
had survived and she has got a very good
look at his face and you know she had
seen what had happened so they kind of
had her testimony now interestingly they
had to move his trial to Peoria Illinois
because it was getting too much you know
publicity in Chicago where it happened
now this I loved this when I saw this in
the in the documentary the sole survivor
of the massacre Cora Amer oh she's on
she's on the witness stand
and they asked her like you know the
attorney as they do they said do you see
the man in the courtroom that did at
blah-dee-blah
and the guy said well I expected her to
just point to him she didn't just do
that she got up got out of the witness
box got right up in his face and pointed
right at his face yeah and said this is
the man right right in his [ __ ] face
and I said man you go girl so yeah that
was like a very dramatic and they said
that like her testimony was pretty much
crucial to getting him convicted they
also had his fingerprints that we method
master everything like that just a rare
situation I mean a random [ __ ]
walks into a damn place as a bunch of
nurses mm-hmm
living there kills eight of them yeah
and then walks out yep it's rare very
rare that this shouldn't happen it
demian have him back in the crazy days
yeah I'd stake my [ __ ] like that did
happen I mean just
this did happen this time yeah but it
just it wasn't normal yes it was
narrowly yeah thankfully yeah but yeah
so it was there like not only the
fingerprint match but also it was pretty
much her testimony that kind of like
cemented so it only took 49 minutes for
the jury to give him a death penalty now
he did get the death penalty at first
but because um that the the Supreme
Court had that thing where they put like
a stay of execution because they you
know for a little while they rolled the
death penalty's unconstitutional so then
you know specs sentence got commuted to
I think he ended up getting eight
successive life sentences which I think
amounted to like maximum twelve hundred
years so they were like never letting
him out even though he was eligible for
parole but he just never got it now I
wanted to mention a little bit that
there's been and I think this is still
kind of like a misconception nowadays
that Richard Speck had XYY syndrome
we're like an extra chromosome yeah
because for a while in the 1960s there
was some mistaken research that seemed
to suggest that XY Y males were more
prone to criminal behavior yeah and like
I said there there didn't seem to be
like a lot of other symptoms of this
particular symptom like this oh they
tended to be quote unquote taller than
average or they had like a lot more acne
than average
they had like learning disabilities like
not anything super noticeable but like
you know enough that so there was like a
lot of brouhaha about that and for a
long time Richard Speck got identified
as having this and that's what made him
a criminal right but later on that was
actually debunked one he was not XY Y
he's completely normal and two even men
that are XY Y and it's actually more
common than you think it's only it's one
in a thousand male births I think you
can't prevent it it's just like a
genetic mutation it doesn't have
anything to do with the parents or
anything like that it just kind of
happens every now and then but it
doesn't it doesn't necessarily increase
criminal behavior they said all it is
it's like sometimes the guy tends to be
taller they're like not like freakishly
tall but you know
six foot one six foot two which is not
like I said it's not that unusual
sometimes they tend out more acne than
usual sometimes they tend to have a
little more learning difficulties in
usual but other than that they don't
really seem to have any problems and
with you know special schooling and you
know just a little bit of extra help
they seem to do fine they have normal
fertility and everything like that so
you know the concept of the ex-wife
imail being like the criminal phenotype
and for a while like Richard Speck was
like oh he's the XYY man he was the one
that they pointed to and sometimes that
still turns up and like some older
genetics textbooks and stuff like that
that he was like the you know the type
that they pointed to we were talking
about that but it's not true
like he didn't 1 XY Y is not as bad as
they made it seem like and to Richards
Beck was not XY Y he was completely
genetically normal I remember an alien 3
the prison that [ __ ] Ripley ended up
falling into was all XY Y chromosome a
oh yeah yeah it's like I said it's not
they just tend to have like a little
more it's it's not you know and they
said as long as it's identified and like
you can give them they can have normal
children yeah if you just give them a
little extra help like I said it's
nothing to do with like it they don't
inherit it from their parents or it's
just a random mutation etic genetic
mutation it can't be prevented or
anything like that but it's not as bad
doesn't make them any more likely to be
criminals or anything like that
so as I said you know when in 1972 when
the Supreme Court ruled the death
penalty unconstitutional you know specks
sentence was commuted to life in prison
or eight consecutive sentences now he
actually was eligible for parole his
first parole hearing took place in 1976
he also had six subsequent hearings the
last of which was in 1990 but of course
he never got it now while he was in
prison he was actually in a prison in he
was first in Stateville Correctional
Center in Crest Hill Illinois he was
actually given the nickname Birdman
because reportedly he had either one or
two sparrows that had flown into his
cell and he kept them as pets
now one source that I read said that
when he was told that he was not allowed
to keep the birds or birds that he threw
them into an
oscillating fan and killed them so you
know that's nice um but while he was
imprisoned they said he was not a model
prisoner because he was real into like
smuggling [ __ ] into the prison like
drugs cigarettes he would put raisins in
jars and he would like stick them like
in the toilet tubes like he was making
you know who she was like letting them
ferment yeah so he was doing a lot of
that kind of [ __ ] but they said other
than that he pretty much kept to himself
just kind of like collected stamps
listen to music and stuff they said that
they they gave him like some work to do
because he seemed like they like they
let him paint the cells and all that
kind of [ __ ] and that seemed to keep him
occupied now when they interviewed him
later on the the very famous thing about
this is that one he got interviewed if
you guys have seen mine hunter which we
talked about before on the Ed Kemper
show spec was one of the 36 criminals
that they did the FBI
you know the nascent behavioral sciences
unit interviewed like in an attempt to
get some insight into how to catch
serial killers and mass murderers and
[ __ ] like that but the special agents
who were at the center of this Johnny
Douglas and Robert Ressler they both
said that Richard Speck didn't seem to
have any particular insights in his own
behavior and he wasn't like super
helpful in that regard because he just
seemed like a big dummy yeah like I said
at first he said he didn't remember
anything
and he said at first that if he had it
to do all over again as in the you know
the apartment Massacre he said oh I'm
kind of sorry as hell about that if I
had it to do all over again it would
just be a burglary I wouldn't have done
that and [ __ ] like that but he said some
different [ __ ] later on he didn't give a
[ __ ] no he really didn't know and he did
admit that later on now famously in 1996
yeah here we go
ya know watch people take take clothes
pay close attention to this so in 1996
Bill Curtis who was a Chicago television
news anchor and is actually fake he's on
like he hosts like a whole [ __ ] ton of
like different true crime shows you will
know him if you see him if you know or
don't recognize his name he got a bunch
of videotapes
what is it Dennis I don't know dances
look at her out he's listening he's Bill
Kurtis gets a bunch of videotapes in the
mail from this anonymous attorney these
had been made in Stateville prison in
1988
now they showed them in front of the
Illinois State Legislature now what was
going on in this [ __ ] not only were a
lot of the inmates openly doing drugs
and we're talking about like piles of
cocaine openly giving oral sex to one
another you know they were just like
giving each other money buying drugs and
stuff so they were trying to show that
it's like look at the [ __ ] that's going
on in the prison it's like there's no no
one's watching them it's like no one
really gives a [ __ ] what they were doing
so they show Richard Speck who was
sitting in there with this other inmate
and he was dressed like a woman - well
he had like normal clothes on it hers
like just like a regular sweatshirt and
he he looked like completely different
like his face was like super wide news
Richard Speck became a woman well that
was probably I didn't look like a woman
he looked like a drunk like like his
face which was like I said all
pockmarked and [ __ ] like that but as he
got older in prison he gained some
weight his face got a lot whiter his
nose got really big I'm guessing that's
from the drinking and also um he grew a
pretty nice set of breasts now there is
some controversy over whether it was
just he got fat and developed some but--
some moobs because i mean he did gain a
lot of weight like he did get pretty
pudgy in prison yeah but some have said
well they snuck in female hormones so he
could take them so that he could become
a queen bee in prison he didn't want to
get killed because he was a rapist and
he was a murderer and apparently you
know he was afraid for his life in this
prison because he had been threatened by
other inmates so he thought that by you
know reportedly he thought that by
turning himself into a more feminine you
know kiss so
other prisoners with like he would make
himself more valuable and keep his ass
from getting killed you have to
understand something
some men are not men deep down unlike me
and when he gets into a prisons type
environment he wants to become the woman
he always wanted to be in that right
Jenny perhaps oh yeah now he did say I
mean when they interviewed him on this
particular videotape this is a pretty
long videotape he did say they asked him
it's like do you like getting [ __ ] by
man and he's like oh yeah absolutely
it's like have you always liked getting
[ __ ] by men he's like sure couldn't
keep the dick out of his mouth yeah and
like I said that was on the videotape I
mean obviously the one that turned a
guy's off yeah on the video it's like
obviously the one that they the the bits
of it that they showed on the biography
show didn't have that but you know they
did describe that that's what happened
in it now interestingly his psychiatrist
are a guy that had done like a lot of
you know psychiatric worked with him his
name was dr. Marvin is a poor in I guess
that's how you pronounce his name he
wrote a book about him afterward he
thought that not only was the quote
unquote
turning into a woman like I said he
still didn't look like a woman he just
looked like a fat old man it was a bit
was a metaphysical woman it was a
mystical woman and have like in and in
the video like the other guy says oh do
you have the blue panties on he's like
yeah and he and then the guy behind the
camera says oh can we see him so he
takes his pants off and he's got like
blue underwear on they weren't like
super frilly or nothing they just looked
like I mean they could have been men's
underwear on us they or they could have
been a men's bathing suit it didn't look
like Superman you know that's what I'm
saying so it's like that's all
imagination that's all imagine so his
psychiatrist thought that not only was
this maybe a survival mechanism like to
keep his ass from getting killed he's
like hey if I turn myself into you know
what were what passes for a woman in
prison then you know I'll have value and
you know therefore it all suck dudes
dicks and stuff and therefore I won't
get beat up or killed but his
psychiatrist also seemed to think that
there might have been an aspect however
unconscious that Richard Speck was
punishing himself by
turning himself into a woman like one
that he had victimized his whole entire
life but not saying that he was aware of
that that that's what he was doing but
the psychiatrist thought that there was
an aspect of that going on as well I
don't think that's what it is well I
think it'd be more than I think what the
deal was let's go back to the suicide
there he knew that he was a failure yeah
he's gonna [ __ ] go out in a blaze of
glory and get a bunch of women and then
be killed or die or kill him kill
himself or go to prison and end his
[ __ ] miserable life but he ended up
in prison yeah didn't want to be who he
was so he wanted to be something new so
he killed the old Richard Speck yeah and
became a new Richard Speck who was a
woman
yeah and in prison he could have a
future as a woman yeah you know even
though like I said he didn't look
anything like a woman yeah but yeah I
didn't even know this I didn't even
realize cuz he's just sitting there
looking like a fat old guy like it he
went shirt or whatever and then he took
his thing off and I'm like huh what big
moves he has like night he went
transgender it didn't look it didn't
look like you and my boobs that you look
like a fat man well you might not think
that he was transgender but in prison in
prisons are different of in his mind he
was transgender even though he did not
look feminine he was it's dumb he he
wasn't
Richard Speck anymore that guy was dead
he's this new woman
yeah that's because he did say like when
they asked him yeah on this video he
said if I if they only knew how much fun
I was having they'd turn me loose yeah
and my kid in a candy house and I saw
that like one guy I can't remember who
it was but one guy like on the
documentary I was watching said you know
what if a hurricane came and bullied
down that prison Richard's back is the
only one that wouldn't leave yeah that
wouldn't escape because he liked it in
there he had status everyone who he was
imagine if you were a dude and you got
locked up in an all-girls school yeah
would you think that was punishment no
you're transgender and you're in a
prison then you're
gonna be the most popular girl in town
yeah in his mind although like I said I
mean I guess instead that yeah because
prison is like a parallel universe yeah
it requires lots of imagination yeah
especially if you well yeah like I said
I saw the dude yes like that dudes they
have life sentences and [ __ ] yeah
they're all and that was the
justification that he gave to for like
doing some of the other [ __ ] like I said
like machen making hooch and you know
like smuggling in cigarettes and whatnot
he's like what are they gonna do to me
I'm already in here for 1,200 years
they're never letting me out so you know
spec was a failure of a man yeah he
became a woman yeah in prison and he was
also probably a failure is it depends
but they did ask him lady and maybe
there are some dudes of prison this saw
saw the female side act beautiful as
though it was just a woman of their
dreams just looking you know walking
down the [ __ ] hallway arm and arm in
front of all the cells and so everybody
just sporting her on his arm like
[ __ ] a jock and a cheerleader got her
yeah like you said it's like a parallel
unit it's a via this it's a world of
imagination yeah like Willy Wonka so on
this same videotape they did ask
Richards back yeah why he had killed
those eight women now like I said
originally he had said that he didn't
remember doing that but obviously that
was [ __ ] now frustratingly
maddeningly all he said as an answer to
that question was it just wasn't there
night that's what he said
yeah well he couldn't stop himself he
just said it wasn't their name yeah and
then he went on to say they said well
did you feel anything about it he said
or they said how did you feel while you
were doing it or after he did it he said
like I all
felt I had no feeling if you're if
you're asking me if I felt sorry no he's
a psychopath yeah he seemed to have like
no and Gulick described some like he
described like that night like what he
happened and he said I think it was
Gloria Davy that he was talking about
and he basically just said oh I just
like flash the knife at her and said get
naked [ __ ] and then the other inmate
like laughs at that like they both laugh
at it like it's the funniest thing ever
it's like well no creepy most
Psychopaths kind of kind of report that
that they don't have much emotions yeah
like really creepy it's really creepy
and it's like creepy to see him like
joking about it like with another guy
they're just like joking about it yeah
so Richard Speck actually ended up dying
in prison of a heart attack
on December 5th 1991 one day before his
50th birthday couldn't happen to a nicer
guy yeah he died young actually he did
die young thankfully well his dad died
at 53 so I'm guessing that kind of brain
of the family um now when he actually
was cremated no one wanted his body his
family yeah yeah no we don't want that
[ __ ] they ended up having to they
cremated him and then only a like I
think only three people like know where
they scattered the ashes just because he
doesn't matter we said some prayers and
like threw him out now one thing I have
heard though like I said even though
there was um some erroneous reports that
he was XYY I had heard that after he
died they actually did an autopsy of his
brain and did find some anomalies in
there that they had never seen before
apparently it was the hippocampus you
know the memory area of your brain and
the amygdala which is you know your rage
and all your emotions and everything and
that these two parts of the brain like
normally they're pretty distinct like in
a regular brain but his in his they were
kind of like overlapping one another
which they thought was very unusual and
they had never seen that before
um so grew up a pissed-off kid so I
guess so so the guy that discovered this
whose name was a young Leeds mom he was
a neuropathologist and he had actually
like taken some slides of like things
and he showed it to like other you know
surgeons and like
brain surgeons stuff and they said yeah
that is super weird but then they never
really followed up on it like a lot of
the tissue samples were lost and like I
said his body ended up being cremated so
they didn't really go any farther with
that but they did say that that was like
one of the as far as I know that's the
only time they ever found that like in a
criminal where those two parts of the
brain were like overlapping so that's
probably pretty much it I don't think
there's much they knew the guy I don't
yeah it's like it just seems like
there's been like a bunch of [ __ ] made
about him there was a there was a movie
called spec that came out in 2002 which
I actually haven't seen the move the
Charles Bronson movie 10:00 to midnight
is kind of a little bit about it look
like loosely based on that who's a
white-trash kid yeah I got it here too
rough upbringing did stupid [ __ ] and
died didn't live well and also killed
eight people actually possibly nine
people and yeah but there's some other
people that was a stupid [ __ ] that he
did and then you know he didn't live
long so I'm gonna guy who died by 50
yeah in prisons for eternity you die not
a successful life yeah any measure I
think and I think I think the crime tape
is famous for murdering those nine girls
was actually kind of like going
supernova but I think it was like a
suicide well it did seem large because
as soon as like a day or two after he
did that like he did attempt suicide I
don't know if it was just because oh I'm
out of here or if he thought he was
gonna get caught he knew he was a loser
and he was gonna go anywhere he could it
really simple job yeah it seemed like he
had really come to like this impasse in
his life and I guess like I said it was
one thing that apparently he had said to
numerous people in his life that he was
gonna like make headlines one day or he
was gonna shock the world one day so I
guess he felt like you know the end was
coming so he had to do something big you
deal with an inadequate man and yet
obviously do something that he could be
recognized for yeah because you can't do
anything like good or Google or anything
like that so it's like you know it's a
way I lashing out at the world because
you're a [ __ ] loser yeah I feel like
that happens a lot in these serial
killer cases it's like they can't get
recognition for something positive or
anything positive or like and
you know like this dynamic of [ __ ]
[ __ ] what he called ego yeah where
they have to have this attention yeah
that they're important yeah they tell
you like yeah they came to this lady in
obscurity yeah just like being regular
person yeah you go look nothing really
that special about you just go ahead and
leave your little life and [ __ ] good
and just find happy yeah it is yeah the
way is for them well obviously they
can't look if they had greater
expectations for themselves yeah I mean
I feel like everybody does to an extent
like a lot of people have like greater
expected they feel like they didn't meet
but most people just move on and deal
with it or at least try to [ __ ] make
some happen
yeah like but even if they do with it
and they don't succeed it's like you
most people like most normal healthy
people you could still live a decent
life can still live a decent life and
find happiness and you know just like
not well I guess when you tell people I
guess was not that hard this when you're
dumb like that though that's not enough
yeah suppose not yeah you have to do
something that's looking heinous well
good because you'll never be as awesome
as you really want to be trying to be
just kind of like I trying to be more
than what you really are type of
situation yeah well yeah and like I said
I feel like that's pretty common with
all these it's like well if I can't do
anything awesome that I have to be like
the biggest monster it was everyone has
to be afraid of me right you know what I
mean I mean what do you think about that
dentist you you should know something
about that well you have to understand
that excellence like me is a [ __ ]
very rare occurrence
that's true I'll give you and they're
trying to trying to do the kind of stuff
that I do but of course they don't have
a talent you have to be an artist you
know and you have to be a good man and
you have to have the discipline to hold
job and raise a family and to be a real
man and they could never be a real man
not around me around me the only he
could be maybe a whoa man but no real
well I picked that up from John Thomas
I'm a big fan of John my god stay back
up here myself yeah
me my cellmate listening to Tom you know
can you stop [ __ ] with me okay
just like now I I was a good show just
just let her well I have to have him in
my office and he'll be like back there
what if you lose the life and like stabs
me in the back one day while I'm working
or something will not pay attention you
be good little buddy okay okay all right
so we're gonna wrap up this show about
Richard Speck and like I said we had a
lot of insight from Dennis Rader which
is always what Dennis [ __ ]
right he's always a big help but it's
always a pleasure to have you on the
show
mr. BTK yeah I bind my torture and I
kill yes yes you do sexy verse 62 I hope
you guys enjoyed it remember if you
liked the show like share subscribe and
all your social media if you'd like to
support the show financially go to our
patreon page or you can go to our blog
at 13 o'clock podcast at wordpress.com
and there's a link to a PayPal account
if you'd like to have a one-time
donation
remember we have our regular episodes
come out every Tuesday we got movie
reviews old movies every Friday new
movies every Sunday and if you are a
patron then you get to see all the stuff
a day early so that's a very exciting so
check it out if you haven't already and
we will see you next time
you
[Music]
you
[Music]